Some trips are just better in an Airbnb. And right now you can discover Canada and their many local hidden gems with an Airbnb. I worked in Canada off and on for two years. Yes. And my first year, the production put me up at a place. And the second year, I was like, hey, whatever that production budget is,
有些旅行住Airbnb会更好。现在你可以通过Airbnb探索加拿大及其众多的当地隐藏宝藏。我在加拿大断断续续工作了两年。是的。第一年，制作组给我安排了住处。第二年，我就想，嘿，不管那笔制作预算是多少，
can I have it and go find my own place in more of a neighborhood, you know? Yes. And I did, I got an Airbnb, I got a little apartment, it faced a park, it was so lovely. I loved the host and I stayed there for two months. Wow. Yeah, and I was near a grocery store.
能不能给我，让我自己去找个更像社区的地方住，你知道吗？是的。我确实这么做了，我租了一个Airbnb，一个小公寓，正对着公园，非常可爱。我喜欢那个房东，我在那里住了两个月。哇。是的，而且我离杂货店很近。
I really felt like I made a little life there. I'm thinking about like the Rocky Mountain areas in Canada where they've got the lakes and the Alberta Rockies. I don't know, it just feels like if you got yourself a cozy little cabin there. You know what I mean? Yeah. Like Banff National Park.
我真的觉得我在那里过上了一种小生活。我在想加拿大落基山脉地区，那里有湖泊和阿尔伯塔落基山脉。我不知道，感觉如果你在那里给自己找个舒适的小木屋。你懂我的意思吗？是的。就像班夫国家公园。
Well listen, maybe you should consider Airbnb for your next adventure. I mean, we love it. Love it. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue? A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart Welcome back to the second drink of Diwali. Yes, Mindy Kaling joined us to talk about her time on The Office and writing this episode.
好吧，听着，也许你应该考虑为你的下一次冒险选择Airbnb。我是说，我们很喜欢它。非常喜欢。还有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响的雪花肋眼牛排更棒的呢？是一块由Instacart购物者精心挑选并送到你家门口的滋滋作响的雪花肋眼牛排。是一块你甚至不用离开儿童戏水池就能订购的雪花肋眼牛排。无论你的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart都能满足你。下载Instacart。欢迎回到《排灯节》的第二杯酒。是的，敏迪·卡灵加入了我们，谈论她在《办公室》的时光以及撰写这一集的过程。
It was a historic episode and it was just, that was such a great interview, hearing about her time on the show and how this episode came about. I'm excited for people to get to re-listen. Yeah, me too. Well, I was going through some of our mail for this episode and one thing we did not ask Mindy
这是具有历史意义的一集，那真是一次很棒的采访，听她讲述在剧组的时光以及这一集是如何诞生的。我很兴奋大家能重新收听。是的，我也是。好吧，我正在整理这一集的邮件，有一件事我们没有问敏迪，
and the Office fans were very curious about was if we knew what Pam actually texted Jim that night of Diwali. If you remember, Jim stayed late at the Stanford branch with Karen and Andy to do some quote, order form consolidating, whatever that means. And then they all end up doing shots. Well, Karen pours hers out, but the boys get a little drunky. And while Jim is zonked out at his desk,
而《办公室》的粉丝们非常好奇，那就是我们是否知道帕姆在排灯节那天晚上到底给吉姆发了什么短信。如果你还记得，吉姆那天晚上和凯伦、安迪留在斯坦福分部加班，做所谓的“订单合并”，不管那意味着什么。然后他们最后都喝了酒。好吧，凯伦倒掉了她的酒，但男孩子们喝得有点醉了。当吉姆在办公桌前昏昏欲睡时，
Pam tries to text him and he doesn't hear his phone buzzing. That's right. So I went to the shooting draft and it did not say what Pam texted. I'm sorry, everyone. Okay. But I did find some extra flirty flirt scenes that we never spoke about.
帕姆试图给他发短信，但他没听到手机震动。没错。所以我查了拍摄剧本，上面没有写帕姆发了什么。抱歉了，各位。好吧。但我确实发现了一些我们从未谈论过的额外调情场景。
One, Rashida Jones does refer to when we ultimately talk to her about her time on the show, but there was more flirty flirt with Jim and Karen. Oh really? Mm-hmm. That got cut out. Listen to how their day started at Stanford. Karen is teasing Jim because Jim has started biking to work,
其中一个，拉什达·琼斯在我们最终谈到她在剧组的时光时确实提到了，但吉姆和凯伦之间还有更多的调情。哦真的吗？嗯。那些被剪掉了。听听他们在斯坦福的一天是怎么开始的。凯伦在取笑吉姆，因为吉姆开始骑自行车上班了，
you know, like their boss. He's kind of sucking up, she thinks. This is how it read. Interior, Stanford office. Jim is photocopying something. Karen comes up behind him in line. Karen says, Josh wants to talk to you. He said it was urgent. Karen says, Josh wants to talk to you. He said it was urgent.
你知道，就像他们的老板一样。她觉得他在拍马屁。剧本是这样写的。内景，斯坦福办公室。吉姆正在复印东西。凯伦排队走到他身后。凯伦说，乔什想和你谈谈。他说很紧急。凯伦说，乔什想和你谈谈。他说很紧急。
Jim says, about what? Karen says, he wanted to know if you want to build a tree house together. Jim looks at his papers and takes a beat. Karen, what? Jim looks at Karen with confidence. I just think it's funny. Karen says, what's funny?
吉姆说，关于什么？凯伦说，他想知道你是否想一起建个树屋。吉姆看着他的文件，停顿了一下。凯伦，什么？吉姆自信地看着凯伦。我只是觉得这很有趣。凯伦说，什么有趣？
Jim says, how obvious it is that you have a huge crush on me. Jim smiles, takes obvious it is that you have a huge crush on me. Jim smiles, takes his papers and leaves. Karen glances at the camera, looking surprised and embarrassed. We followed Jim who has an amazed look on his face, like, did I actually say that?
吉姆说，你对我迷恋得这么明显，这很有趣。吉姆微笑着，拿起文件离开了。凯伦瞥了一眼摄像机，看起来既惊讶又尴尬。我们跟着吉姆，他脸上带着一种惊讶的表情，好像在说，我真的说了那句话吗？
Oh. Gasps. Yes. Wow. Well, when we discussed this episode for the first time, Rashida shared with us that there was a scene they filmed where Jim and Karen go out for drinks and get tipsy and make out.
哦。倒吸一口凉气。是的。哇。好吧，当我们第一次讨论这一集时，拉什达告诉我们，他们拍过一个场景，吉姆和凯伦出去喝酒，喝醉了并亲热。
Oh yeah, we cover that in great detail in this episode, but there was a couplet of dialogue that was in the shooting draft that we didn't read in our first breakdown. Is it more flirty flirt? It's their makeout scene. And it does mention that moment where Jim gets the text from Pam, and that's what fans were curious about.
哦对，我们在这一集中详细讨论了这一点，但拍摄剧本中有一段对话我们在第一次解析时没有读到。是更多的调情吗？是他们的亲热戏。而且确实提到了吉姆收到帕姆短信的那一刻，这就是粉丝们好奇的地方。
So I thought we should share it with them. My inner Pam is having a lot of turmoil over these discoveries. Here is how it read. Interior, Stanford bar. We see Jim and Karen having drinks, sitting on the same side of a small romantic table. Jim says, at my old office,
所以我认为我们应该和他们分享。我内心的帕姆对这些发现感到非常不安。剧本是这样写的。内景，斯坦福酒吧。我们看到吉姆和凯伦在喝酒，坐在一个小浪漫桌子的同一侧。吉姆说，在我以前的办公室，
I was the one who pulled pranks. Karen says, really? We all think you're so timid. Jim says, wow. Jim's phone buzzes on the table. Karen says, who texted you? Jim glances at it, turns off his phone. Jim says, not important.
我才是那个搞恶作剧的人。凯伦说，真的吗？我们都以为你很胆小。吉姆说，哇。吉姆的手机在桌子上震动。凯伦说，谁给你发的短信？吉姆瞥了一眼，关掉了手机。吉姆说，不重要。
Karen smiles. Jim kisses her. He looked at his phone, Jim says, not important. Karen smiles, Jim kisses her. He looked at his phone, saw it was Pam, turned it off. Wow. Mm-hmm. So these scenes would really have changed these characters' journeys. Oh yeah.
凯伦笑了。吉姆吻了她。他看了看手机，吉姆说，不重要。凯伦笑了，吉姆吻了她。他看了看手机，发现是帕姆，就关掉了。哇。嗯。所以这些场景真的会改变这些角色的旅程。哦是的。
So I have to ask, did any of them make it into the superfan version? The superfan version does have an extra six minutes of footage, but no. These extra Jim and Karen scenes are not included, probably because Dave Rogers, you know, is steadfast at protecting the original storylines of the show, thankfully.
所以我必须问，其中任何一个场景进入了超级粉丝版本吗？超级粉丝版本确实有额外的六分钟镜头，但没有。这些额外的吉姆和凯伦的场景没有被包括在内，可能是因为戴夫·罗杰斯，你知道，非常坚定地保护剧集的原始故事情节，谢天谢地。
Well, I thank you, Dave Rogers, because my Pam Hart could barely take Angela reading them. My goodness. I mean, jump swagger. Yeah. Like, I can't believe you're so into me. I mean, listen, Pam makes a connection at the Diwali party herself.
好吧，我感谢你，戴夫·罗杰斯，因为我的帕姆心几乎无法承受安吉拉读这些内容。天哪。我是说，吉姆的傲慢。是的。就像，我不敢相信你这么迷我。我是说，听着，帕姆自己在排灯节派对上也建立了一种联系。
Yes. You know, so it's not like she's some wilting wallflower on this evening, but... Well, thank you everyone for writing in, and now here is your second drink of Diwali. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together.
是的。你知道，所以她并不是那天晚上的那种枯萎的壁花，但是……好吧，谢谢大家的来信，现在这是你们的《排灯节》第二杯酒。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。
And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone.
我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。大家好。
Hi, you guys. Welcome to Diwali. I'm so excited for this episode, Jenna. Me, too. It's a great episode, and we have a great special guest. I just want to get to it. Alright, well this is season three, episode six. It was directed by Miguel Arteta and written by our special guest, Mindy Kaling.
嗨，你们好。欢迎来到排灯节。我为这一集感到非常兴奋，珍娜。我也是。这是一集很棒的剧集，我们有一位很棒的特别嘉宾。我只想直接开始。好吧，这是第三季第六集。由米格尔·阿特塔执导，由我们的特别嘉宾敏迪·卡灵编剧。
Woohoo! Very, very exciting. Well let's get to it. We are going to waste no time. I'm starting with a summary. Do it. In this episode, everyone from Dunder Mifflin attends a traditional Indian celebration of Diwali in honor of Kelly.
呜呼！非常非常令人兴奋。好吧，让我们开始吧。我们不会浪费时间。我从摘要开始。开始吧。在这一集中，邓德·米夫林的所有人都参加了为纪念凯利而举办的传统印度排灯节庆祝活动。
Now, Ryan is going to meet Kelly's parents, who are really less than impressed with his commitment to their daughter. Well, to be fair, he says with extra money he wants to travel and get like an Xbox or something. So, you know. Yes. I think I would also be less than impressed.
现在，瑞安要去见凯利的父母，他们对瑞安对他们女儿的承诺印象并不深刻。好吧，公平地说，他说他想用多余的钱去旅行，买个Xbox之类的东西。所以，你知道。是的。我想我也会印象不深刻。
Meanwhile, Michael proposes to his girlfriend, Carol. Oh, Michael. Wow. Oh, Michael. Michael takes a big step. In front of a lot of strangers. Yeah. So a bit of a crash and burn. So awkward. Pam enjoys herself for the first time as a single person, and Angela guards the shoes while eating some dry naan.
与此同时，迈克尔向他的女朋友卡罗尔求婚。哦，迈克尔。哇。哦，迈克尔。迈克尔迈出了很大的一步。在很多陌生人面前。是的。所以有点搞砸了。太尴尬了。帕姆第一次作为单身人士享受自己，而安吉拉在吃干馕的同时看守鞋子。
Very dry naan. And over at the Stanford office, Jim, Andy, and Karen work late into the night and booze it up. Yeah, Jaeger-meister. I mean, what the heck? So gross. Andy is a maniac. I'm going to give you fast fact number one.
非常干的馕。而在斯坦福办公室，吉姆、安迪和凯伦加班到深夜，喝得酩酊大醉。是的，野格利口酒。我是说，搞什么鬼？太恶心了。安迪是个疯子。我要给你第一个快速事实。
This is a really special episode because The Office was the first American television comedy series to depict the Hindu festival of Diwali. I love that. Way to go, The Office. It aired November 2, 2006, and it was seen by 8.8 million people on the night that it first aired. And now it's been seen by how many people? I don't even know. Did you know what Diwali was, Jenna, when we got the script? Shelby B. asked the same question, and I did not know about Diwali. Did you know about Diwali?
这是非常特别的一集，因为《办公室》是第一部描绘印度排灯节的美国电视喜剧系列。我喜欢这一点。干得好，《办公室》。它于2006年11月2日播出，首播当晚有880万人观看。现在有多少人看过了？我甚至不知道。珍娜，当我们拿到剧本时，你知道什么是排灯节吗？谢尔比·B问了同样的问题，我不知道排灯节。你知道排灯节吗？
I did, but I grew up overseas. I grew up in Indonesia. Bali has a very big Hindu population. So I had heard of Diwali, and I thought it was awesome that we were going to do an episode about it. Had you ever celebrated Diwali? I hadn't ever celebrated it, but myself, I went to an international school.
我知道，但我是在海外长大的。我在印度尼西亚长大。巴厘岛有很大的印度教人口。所以我听说过排灯节，我觉得我们要拍一集关于它的剧集真是太棒了。你庆祝过排灯节吗？我从来没有庆祝过，但我自己上的是国际学校。
They did recognize many holidays, and there was a Diwali day. Yeah, well, they do that at my kid's school now. They have a day where they celebrate Diwali, which I think is really cool, especially since I grew up not knowing about it. It is so beautiful and it was so fun. I remember we were all really giddy. Of course, this meant we got to leave the office.
他们确实承认许多节日，有一个排灯节。是的，好吧，他们现在在我孩子的学校也这样做。他们有一天庆祝排灯节，我觉得这很酷，尤其是因为我长大时不知道它。它太美了，太有趣了。我记得我们当时都很兴奋。当然，这意味着我们可以离开办公室。
That brings me to fast fact number two, Angela. Fan question from Juliet G and Phoebe Tomac, where did you shoot the scenes when you were celebrating Diwali? Well, guess who I went to for the answer. Does it rhyme with Shmentish media? It does, and we have a sting for it. You do?
这让我想到了第二个快速事实，安吉拉。朱丽叶·G和菲比·托马克的问题，你们拍摄排灯节庆祝场景是在哪里？好吧，猜猜我去找谁要答案了。它押韵“Shmentish媒体”吗？是的，我们有一个它的音效。你有吗？
Kenta, Kenta, Kenta, Kenta, Kenta, Kenta, Kenta, Kenta. Ha ha ha ha ha. Ha ha ha ha. Yes, Angela, that was sent in by Tyler Beckwith, and we love it, Tyler. Thank you for our Kenta-Pedia stage. It is really great. It sounds like something out of like a 1980s action kind of movie. Exactly. Well, Kenta-Pedia told us that Diwali was shot at Grant High School.
肯塔，肯塔，肯塔，肯塔，肯塔，肯塔，肯塔，肯塔。哈哈哈哈。哈哈哈哈。是的，安吉拉，那是泰勒·贝克威斯寄来的，我们很喜欢它，泰勒。谢谢我们的肯塔百科舞台。它真的很棒。听起来像是1980年代动作电影里的东西。完全正确。好吧，肯塔百科告诉我们，排灯节是在格兰特高中拍摄的。
We shot most of the scenes in their gym, which is called Grant Hall, and we shot there at the end of August, and school was in session. They had just started up the school year. He said that we shot there for three full days, and we had to work around the school schedule, because like school was happening in the hallways. I have such a fond
我们大部分场景是在他们的体育馆拍摄的，叫格兰特大厅，我们在八月底在那里拍摄，学校正在上课。他们刚开始学年。他说我们在那里拍了整整三天，我们必须围绕学校的时间表工作，因为走廊里正在上课。我有如此美好的
memory of our time shooting there because they they parked our trailers facing sort of like a little field with some trees and normally they were just in a asphalt parking lot and so I would open my door and there'd be trees and grass and Brian brought a football and we like tossed the football out in the grass and I have such fond memories of this whole week. I remember it too for those exact same reasons. Well this school is host to a lot of filmmaking including Freaks and Geeks, Black-ish, Malcolm in the Middle and True Blood and I've got a little bit of trivia for you. Yeah? Melora Hardin went to Grant High School.
在那拍摄的回忆，因为他们把我们的拖车停在面对一个小草坪和一些树的地方，通常它们只是停在沥青停车场，所以我打开门就能看到树和草，布莱恩带了一个橄榄球，我们在草地上扔橄榄球，我对这一整周都有美好的回忆。我也记得，正是因为同样的原因。好吧，这所学校举办了很多电影拍摄，包括《怪胎与书呆子》、《黑人一家亲》、《马尔科姆的一家》和《真爱如血》，我有一点琐事要告诉你。是吗？梅洛拉·哈丁去了格兰特高中。
Get out of town. Yeah, we shot at her alma mater. Wow, I love that. She's like a true sort of like Hollywood kid, you know? Like there's all these things from her life, like right here. To me, it's still all sort of like, I still feel like a transplant in some ways in Los Angeles.
别开玩笑了。是的，我们在她的母校拍摄的。哇，我喜欢这个。她就像一个真正的“好莱坞孩子”，你知道吗？就像她生活中的所有这些事情，就在这里。对我来说，这仍然有点像，在某种程度上，我仍然觉得自己在洛杉矶是个外来者。
Like still to this day, if I'm ever out and about and I see the Hollywood sign, I'm like, there's a Hollywood sign, oh my God, it's a Hollywood sign. But if I drive by and I see like a film crew filming something on the street, I get as excited as if they pulled up in my neighborhood in St. Louis as a kid. I'm like, ooh, what are they filming?
就像直到今天，如果我在外面看到好莱坞标志，我还是会说，那是好莱坞标志，天哪，那是好莱坞标志。但如果我开车经过，看到剧组在街上拍东西，我就会像小时候在圣路易斯看到他们开进我的社区一样兴奋。我会说，噢，他们在拍什么？
Oh, look, I wonder what it is. I wonder if we can find out who's the star. Yeah, I look. Like, I get that same reaction still. Yeah, me too. I drive by and I try to see, is like, is there someone famous out there? Exactly.
哦，看，我想知道那是什么。我想知道我们能不能找出谁是明星。是的，我看了。就像，我仍然有同样的反应。是的，我也是。我开车经过，试图看看，有没有名人？完全正确。
So true. Well, I'm going to move us along, Angela, because I know we want to get to our interview with Mindy. Fast fact number three. I said earlier this was directed by Miguel Arteta. Angela, I was such a huge fan of Miguel. When I found out he was going to direct this episode, this is the only episode he directed, I completely geeked out.
太真实了。好吧，我要继续了，安吉拉，因为我知道我们想进行对敏迪的采访。第三个快速事实。我之前说过这一集是由米格尔·阿特塔执导的。安吉拉，我是米格尔的超级粉丝。当我发现他要执导这一集时，这是他执导的唯一一集，我完全疯狂了。
Okay, he had directed this little... Did you go up to him? Were you dorky? What'd you do? Oh, Angela, I followed him around the entire week. We bonded. At the end of this week, I thought we were best friends and would work together forever on every future project. And I'm not gonna lie, every time there was, like, a script that I was sent or when I was trying to produce
好吧，他执导过这个小……你去找他了吗？你表现得像个书呆子吗？你做了什么？哦，安吉拉，我那一整周都跟着他。我们建立了联系。在那周结束时，我以为我们是最好的朋友，并且会在未来的每一个项目中永远一起工作。我不撒谎，每次有寄给我的剧本，或者当我试图自己制作
a movie myself, he was the first person I would go to because I was like... I'm literally like, this guy is a genius. I love him. I love that. I didn't know you were like following him around everywhere. Oh, yeah. I wanted everything about him to rub off on me. So he had directed this little indie movie called Chuck and Buck written by and starring
一部电影时，他是我第一个会去找的人，因为我当时……我简直就像，这家伙是个天才。我爱他。我喜欢这个。我不知道你到处跟着他。哦，是的。我希望他的一切都能感染我。所以他执导过一部名为《查克和巴克》的小型独立电影，由
Mike White, who by the way, you're also obsessed have stocked. Yeah, I know way, I also have stalked. Yeah, I know that you stalked him. I got to work with him, and then that made me feel one step closer to Mike White, who I eventually managed to stalk and become, I became friends with Mike White, and then I eventually got to be in a Mike White movie starring Ben Stiller.
迈克·怀特编剧并主演，顺便说一句，你也是痴迷并跟踪过他。是的，我知道，我也跟踪过。我知道你跟踪过他。我有机会和他一起工作，那让我觉得离迈克·怀特更近了一步，我最终设法跟踪并成为了朋友，我最终有机会出演了一部由本·斯蒂勒主演的迈克·怀特电影。
And then after that happened, I was like, well, I can now retire because I have worked with my idol. I wrote in my journal about this week. Do you want to hear what I wrote, lady? Of course. I always want to hear about your journal. Your journal delights me.
在那之后，我就想，好吧，我现在可以退休了，因为我已经和我的偶像一起工作了。我在日记里写了这一周。你想听听我写了什么吗，女士？当然。我总是想听听你的日记。你的日记让我很高兴。
That's- It does. That's going to be your autobiography. A journal delights me, by Jenna Fischer. I wrote that and I wrote this. Me and the adorable Mindy Kaling are gonna be doing really early morning interviews together on all the local NBC stations. We are gonna talk to 16 cities
那是——它确实。那将是你的自传。《日记让我很高兴》，作者：珍娜·费舍尔。我写了那个，我还写了这个。我和可爱的敏迪·卡灵将在所有当地NBC电台一起做非常早的晨间采访。我们将和16个城市交谈，
and we have to get up at 5 a.m. Oh my gosh, you guys did a little press junket. I think this is my very first one. Well, what's crazy about that, Angela, is you probably then, after you were done, had to come to work. Oh yeah, because we had to, I remember we had to be on stage.
我们必须在早上5点起床。天哪，你们做了一个小新闻发布会。我想这是我的第一次。好吧，关于这一点疯狂的是，安吉拉，你可能在结束后不得不去上班。哦是的，因为我们必须，我记得我们必须上台。
We actually did them on the set, with the set as the background, and we got there and we met this satellite media tour, is what they called it, and we met their crew, and we had to be there at 4 a.m. to go through hair and makeup and then we started doing interviews at 5 a.m. and we talked to a new city every 15 minutes for 3 hours. Wow. Yeah. And now you did it with Mindy. Mindy was my first press junket. Well this is a wonderful segue into our upcoming segment. We'll take a break but
我们实际上是在片场做的，以片场为背景，我们到了那里，遇到了这个卫星媒体巡回，他们是这么叫的，我们遇到了他们的工作人员，我们必须在凌晨4点到达那里进行发型和化妆，然后我们在早上5点开始采访，我们每15分钟和一个新城市交谈，持续3个小时。哇。是的。现在你和敏迪一起做了。敏迪是我的第一次新闻发布会。好吧，这是一个进入我们即将到来的环节的精彩过渡。我们将休息一下，但
when we come back, we're going to play our interview with Mindy Kaling. She came and talked to us. It was amazing. It was such a joy to have her here. And I'm so excited for you guys to listen to this. And then afterwards, we're going to fully break down the episode. We'll get to that right after the break. We'll see you with Mindy.
当我们回来时，我们将播放对敏迪·卡灵的采访。她来和我们谈了。太棒了。有她在这里真是太高兴了。我非常兴奋你们能听到这个。然后之后，我们将全面解析这一集。我们将在休息后立即进行。我们稍后见敏迪。
Mindy Kaling, hi! Hi guys. I'm so happy to be here. Welcome to office ladies. I'm giving you a hug through the Zoomie Zoom. Thank you. Congrats you guys on the massive success of this. This is like, this is awesome. This is everyone in my life is obviously such a fan
敏迪·卡灵，嗨！嗨，伙计们。我很高兴来到这里。欢迎来到《办公室》女士。我通过Zoom给你一个拥抱。谢谢。恭喜你们取得了巨大的成功。这就像，这太棒了。这是我生命中的每个人显然都是粉丝，
and I'm like, I'm so proud of you guys. This is so great. Thank you. Thanks, Mindy. Yeah, of course. We love it. We're having a good time. It's fun to hear the way that the show was
我当时想，我为你们感到骄傲。这太棒了。谢谢。谢谢，敏迪。是的，当然。我们喜欢它。我们玩得很开心。听到你们眼中的剧集很有趣，
through your guys' eyes, because it's so loving and fun and super accurate. And I like, I'm really so loving and fun and super accurate. And I like, I'm really enjoying it. So this is great. Thanks for having me. Thank you. That was so nice.
因为它非常有爱、有趣且超级准确。我喜欢，我真的很享受。所以这太棒了。谢谢你们邀请我。谢谢。那太好了。
I feel like this is all just pure joy. I'm just so delighted to see you and to talk to you. And this is such a fun episode. So we just get to reminisce a little bit. Love it. Well, before we get into Diwali, we always like to ask all of our guests their office origin story. So how did you come to be on the show? Well, it was 2004 and I had I was off doing a play off off-Broadway
我觉得这一切纯粹是快乐。看到你并和你交谈，我感到非常高兴。这一集太有趣了。所以我们只是回忆一下。喜欢它。好吧，在进入排灯节之前，我们总是喜欢问我们所有的嘉宾他们的《办公室》起源故事。那么你是怎么来到这个剧组的？好吧，那是2004年，我当时在纽约做一部外百老汇戏剧，
in New York called Matt and Ben, which was a play that I wrote with my writing partner and friend at the time, Brenda Withers, where it's like an hour long short play where I play Ben Affleck and she plays Matt Damon. It's so hard to tell the story without being like, just being like, okay, so just ignore that kind of interesting fact and move on. But so we did that, it won the Fringe Festival,
叫《马特和本》，那是我和当时的写作伙伴兼朋友布伦达·威瑟斯一起写的剧本，这是一个一小时的短剧，我扮演本·阿弗莱克，她扮演马特·戴蒙。很难讲述这个故事而不像，只是说，好吧，所以忽略那个有趣的琐事继续前进。但我们做了那个，它赢得了边缘艺术节，
got some attention and sort of was our entree to LA. And when we were in LA, I had like an Arrested Development spec and then that play. And I had very few meetings. The climate for hiring writers, if you were like an untested Indian American woman, it was very different 16 years ago than it is now. And the only place that I got an interview at,
得到了一些关注，算是我们进入洛杉矶的入场券。当我们在洛杉矶时，我有一个《发展受阻》的剧本，然后是那部戏。我几乎没有会议。如果你是一个未经测试的印度裔美国女性，招聘编剧的气候与现在完全不同，那是16年前。我唯一得到面试的地方，
I got two interviews, one was at Nevermind Nirvana, which was a pilot about an Indian family. And I was like, yes, I could write on that show. And the other one was The Office. And I remember Joey was like, do you guys remember how huge Joey was when we started shooting? Yeah. Oh yeah.
我得到了两次面试，一次是在《没关系，涅槃》，那是一个关于印度家庭的试播集。我当时想，是的，我可以在那个节目里写剧本。另一个是《办公室》。我记得乔伊当时……你们记得我们开始拍摄时乔伊有多火吗？是的。哦是的。
The Friends spinoff. It was like the NBC, think they put all their money in that. And then Father of the Pride. Do you guys remember that one? No. Father of the Pride was a cartoon, a Jeffrey Katzenberg produced cartoon about,
《老友记》的衍生剧。就像NBC，我想他们把所有的钱都投进去了。然后是《骄傲之父》。你们记得那个吗？不。 《骄傲之父》是一部卡通片，由杰弗里·卡森伯格制作，关于
from the point of view of two tigers that worked with Siegfried and Roy. Oh yes. What? Yes, it's coming back to me. And it was an animated show. This sounds like a bit on Saturday Night Live. This doesn't sound like a TV show.
从两只与齐格弗里德和罗伊一起工作的老虎的角度来看。哦是的。什么？是的，我想起来了。这是一部动画片。这听起来像是《周六夜现场》的一个片段。这听起来不像是一个电视节目。
Not only was it a real show, it was like the hottest show. Like you could not get an interview. So I didn't get an interview on Will and Grace. I didn't get an interview at Joey and I didn't get an interview at Father of the Pride. And you can imagine like just to show how things have become so different from then, like, can you imagine like now like a minority woman who won the Fringe Festival
它不仅是一个真正的节目，它还是最热门的节目。就像你根本得不到面试机会。所以我没有得到《威尔和格蕾丝》的面试，没有得到《乔伊》的面试，也没有得到《骄傲之父》的面试。你可以想象，就像为了展示事情变得多么不同，就像，你能想象现在一个赢得边缘艺术节的少数族裔女性
coming out to LA, not getting a meeting on like, on all the two shows. So these have changed a lot, so that's great. But the two people who I got interviews with, Nevermind Nirvana, and I went into their offices in Burbank, and this has never happened to me before, but I sat in the office, and as I was there waiting to meet the showrunner,
来到洛杉矶，在两个节目上都得不到会议吗？所以这些改变了很多，这太棒了。但我得到面试的两个人，《没关系，涅槃》，我去了他们在伯班克的办公室，这对我来说以前从未发生过，但我坐在办公室里，当我等待见制片人时，
they got the call that the pilot hadn't been picked up to series. So I sat there and then the assistant came out and was like, you should go home, like there's no jobs. So I just like got up and left. And then the second one was at the office with Greg Daniels. And so I met with him. And just so you know, my agent at the time, who I won't mention, was really like,
他们接到电话说试播集没有被预订成系列。所以我坐在那里，然后助理出来说，你应该回家，没有工作了。所以我只是起身离开了。第二个是在《办公室》和格雷格·丹尼尔斯一起。所以我见了他。顺便说一句，我当时的经纪人，我就不提名字了，真的说，
yeah, this show doesn't have a lot of heat. I don't think it's really gonna do anything. Everyone likes the British one better. So it's just like, you know, it's good to meet Greg Daniels. He's done a lot of good stuff, but it's just good to have a general. So I went in there and there was not a lot of stakes and I had a very, a really fun interview with Greg
是的，这个节目没什么热度。我不认为它真的会做什么。每个人都更喜欢英国版。所以，你知道，见见格雷格·丹尼尔斯很好。他做了很多好事，但只是做一个常规会面很好。所以我进去了，没什么赌注，我和格雷格进行了一次非常有趣的面试，
that lasted two hours, but you guys know Greg. So it was actually probably only 15 minutes of talking in two hours. And then he hired me. And, or he didn't hire me in the meeting, like they still had to do up-fronts and everything. But we had a great meeting and I heard it went well. And then a month and a half later I was told I was coming back for six episodes, such a
持续了两个小时，但你们了解格雷格。所以实际上可能只有15分钟的谈话在两个小时里。然后他雇用了我。或者他在会议中没有雇用我，他们仍然必须做前期准备等等。但我们进行了一次很棒的会议，我听说进行得很顺利。然后一个半月后，我被告知我要回来拍六集，第一季太
small first season. But I was so new. And I think you guys were new enough too that it was just like, oh my gosh, any episodes? That's fantastic. Not knowing that that was kind of an unusually small number of episodes. But that was how I got on The Office. And how did you end up then playing a role on the show? You know, Greg had put into the contract these acting, these writing contract, these acting clauses for I think a number of the writers.
小了。但我太新了。我想你们也足够新，以至于就像，哦天哪，任何剧集？那太棒了。不知道那是一个异常小的剧集数量。但这就是我进入《办公室》的方式。那你后来是怎么在剧中扮演角色的？你知道，格雷格在合同中加入了这些表演，这些写作合同，这些表演条款，我想是针对一些编剧的。
At least it was in my and I think Paul Lieberstein's. So I guess in the back of his mind, he was thinking in those terms, but the first season classic episode, Diversity Day written by the great BJ Novak. I remember in the room, he loved this idea, Greg loved this idea of Michael Scott offending all these people,
至少在我和保罗·利伯斯坦的合同里有。所以我想在他的脑海里，他在考虑这些条款，但第一季经典剧集《多样性日》，由伟大的BJ·诺瓦克编写。我记得在房间里，他喜欢这个想法，格雷格喜欢这个想法，迈克尔·斯科特冒犯所有这些人，
but it's kind of the funniest version of it when there's some minority people there, who can get extra offended. So at that time, I think it just made sense to have another minority person. And I was like, I'll do it. I actually, I didn't go through, he's like, he, I had two lines in that episode and he said, do you want to be in it? I was like, of course. Um, and so diversity day.
但当有一些少数族裔在那里时，这是最有趣的版本，他们可以被额外冒犯。所以在那个时候，我想有另一个少数族裔是有道理的。我当时想，我会做的。我实际上，我没有经历，他就像，他，我在那一集里有两句台词，他说，你想参与吗？我当时想，当然。嗯，所以多样性日。
Yeah. Thank heavens that was the second episode. Cause then that guest starred then. And so, Diversity Day, yeah, thank heavens that was the second episode, because then that guest starred then and I think maybe once or twice that first season I wasn't in it very much. And then second season was like, I sort of saw, I got more lines. And yeah, that's how it happened. What blew me away, Mindy, is when I think back on that and I was sort of reading back
是的，谢天谢地那是第二集。因为那时客串了。所以，多样性日，是的，谢天谢地那是第二集，因为那时客串了，我想第一季可能有一两次我参与得不多。然后第二季就像，我看到，我得到了更多的台词。是的，事情就是这样发生的。让我震惊的是，敏迪，当我回想那个时候，我正在阅读
on, you know, Wikipedia about all of us and where we were at in our lives at that time and you were 24. And that blows my mind. You had your act together for me, for someone at 24. You were amazing because at 24, I was, I think I was doing takeout at Chin Chin's. I wasn't a waiter. I was just doing a hostess job. Do you know what it is?
关于我们所有人以及当时我们在生活中的位置的维基百科，你当时24岁。这让我震惊。对于24岁的人来说，你已经准备好了。你太棒了，因为在24岁时，我，我想我当时在Chin Chin's做外卖。我不是服务员。我只是做接待员的工作。你知道那是什么吗？
Well, thank you for saying that. I mean, I love to feel like I was a wunderkind, but do you know what it is? Is that it's just the life of a writer, a comedy writer and the life of an actor. They're just so, they're so different, right? Like it's so, it's very hard to break into comedy writing, but I do think that is easier than breaking into acting.
好吧，谢谢你这么说。我是说，我喜欢感觉自己是个神童，但你知道那是什么吗？就是编剧的生活，喜剧编剧和演员的生活。它们太，太不同了，对吧？就像进入喜剧写作非常困难，但我确实认为这比进入表演更容易。
Because if you can write, you can write your own opportunities and write a spec script that then you can use and send out. Whereas when you're a young actor, you're like, I just hope someone calls me in to see something. So thank you for saying that. But it felt less special because BJ is there and he was the same age
因为如果你能写，你就能创造自己的机会，写一个剧本，然后你可以使用并发送出去。而当你是一个年轻演员时，你会想，我只是希望有人叫我去试镜。所以谢谢你这么说。但这感觉没那么特别，因为BJ在那里，他也是同样的年龄，
and he'd already written on a show at 24. So it's just when I was like, oh, I guess I'm like young and cool. He was like, oh yeah, I've already worked on, he was on a Bob Saget sitcom and Mike Schur was like 28 and had already had like an Emmy and been at SNL for nine years or something crazy. So there was no sense of like, you could ever think you were special or like ahead of the curve or anything like that
而且他在24岁时已经在一个节目里写过剧本了。所以当我当时想，哦，我想我很年轻很酷。他就像，哦是的，我已经工作过，他在鲍勃·萨格特的情景喜剧里，迈克·舒尔当时28岁，已经有了艾美奖，并且在SNL工作了九年或者类似疯狂的事情。所以根本没有那种，你永远不会认为自己很特别或者领先于潮流之类的感觉
with that group of people. Well, I always thought you were special. Thank you. Thanks Angela. All right, should we get into this episode Jenna? Yeah. Yes. Did you get a chance to rewatch it?
和那群人在一起。好吧，我一直认为你很特别。谢谢。谢谢安吉拉。好吧，我们要进入这一集吗，珍娜？是的。是的。你有机会重温它吗？
Yes, I did. What was it like for you to rewatch it? I have to say, I feel really lucky that Greg wanted to do this episode because it feels like now Angela was on my most recent show and we did an episode about Ganesh Pooja and there's so much more, there's so many more shows on the air with diverse casts and everything. But the fact that on primetime television, and I don't know, what year so many more shows on the air with like diverse cast and everything But the fact that on prime time television and I don't know what year did it come out 2007? Maybe it aired November 2nd 2006 it was seen by 8.8 million people and it was the first American television comedy series to depict the Hindu Festival of Diwali
是的，我看了。重温它对你来说是什么感觉？我必须说，我觉得自己真的很幸运，格雷格想做这一集，因为感觉现在安吉拉在我最近的节目里，我们做了一集关于象神节的内容，现在有更多的节目，有更多的节目在播出，有多元化的演员阵容等等。但事实上在黄金时段电视上，我不知道，它是哪一年出来的？2007年？也许是2006年11月2日播出的，有880万人观看，它是第一部描绘印度排灯节的美国电视喜剧系列。
It was the very first one. That's cool That's amazing. Go us for doing that. And you know, the show Mindy's referring to is Never Have I Ever. Mindy, I do want to give it a little plug here because it's so great and the cast is great and you're with them from the beginning.
它是第一部。那很酷。那太棒了。为我们这样做而喝彩。你知道，敏迪提到的节目是《好想做一次》。敏迪，我确实想在这里给它一个小广告，因为它太棒了，演员阵容很棒，你从一开始就和他们在一起。
The young actors you got, I felt a hundred years old on that set. So did I. So did everyone who wasn't 17. Oh my God. And they were so cute and I loved the office so much. Oh my gosh. They were so starstruck by you, Angela.
你找到的年轻演员，我在那个片场感觉自己有一百岁了。我也是。所有不是17岁的人都一样。哦天哪。他们太可爱了，我非常喜欢《办公室》。哦天哪。他们被你迷住了，安吉拉。
It was so special that you got to be there. Oh my gosh. Mimi, what is the name of the lead actress on that show? Maitreyi Ramakrishnan. I adore her. Oh. Because when you watch the show, you are so immediately in with her journey.
你能去那里真是太特别了。哦天哪。敏迪，那个节目的女主角叫什么名字？麦特瑞·拉玛克里斯南。我崇拜她。哦。因为当你观看这个节目时，你立刻就进入了她的旅程。
Immediately. She is so effervescent and open and just, wow, what a find. What a find. Thank you. She's going to flip out. Jenna, Office is her number one favorite show. If you go on her social media for more than two days, there's an Office meme or there's like, yeah, I bet you've been on her Instagram, like with the,
立刻。她如此活泼、开放，哇，真是个发现。真是个发现。谢谢。她会疯掉的。珍娜，《办公室》是她最喜欢的节目。如果你去她的社交媒体超过两天，就会有一个《办公室》的梗，或者就像，是的，我敢打赌你去过她的Instagram，就像，
like, please don't throw trash at me. Like just like some, like famous Pam line. Okay, so, so here we go. So now we have Diwali, the Festival of Lights. It's on network TV. Mindy, you have been so amazing at just really, I feel like representing all different sides of culture and on television.
就像，请不要向我扔垃圾。就像一些，就像著名的帕姆台词。好吧，所以，所以我们开始吧。所以现在我们有了排灯节，灯光节。它在电视网上。敏迪，你在电视上真正代表了文化的所有不同方面，你一直都很棒。
It's just, you should know what it's meant to people. We had a lot of people write in about having their community seen in this mainstream way, what it meant to them. It's really moving. Oh, wow. That's so nice. I mean, you know, one of the harder things about when you write the Diwali episode is like, we couldn't believe that Greg said yes,
你应该知道这对人们意味着什么。我们有很多来信说，以这种主流方式看到他们的社区对他们意味着什么。这真的很感人。哦，哇。那太好了。我是说，你知道，当你写排灯节这一集时，比较困难的事情之一就是，我们不敢相信格雷格答应了，
because normally we would do like a Halloween episode at that time of year, because it's the end of October. But then when he said yes, I had to kind of confront the fact that I'm Indian American, I don't know very much about the holiday. And that that experience of being Indian American and talking about how you don't know very much about the holiday kind of became a big part of the episode, which I loved. I liked that Greg thought that was just as interesting, if not more interesting than
因为通常我们在那一年的那个时候会做一集万圣节，因为那是十月底。但当他答应时，我不得不面对我是印度裔美国人，我对这个节日了解不多的事实。而那种作为印度裔美国人，谈论你对这个节日了解不多的经历，在某种程度上成为了这一集的重要部分，我很喜欢。我喜欢格雷格认为这同样有趣，如果不是比
me going and like pretending that like my family and I were these experts at Hindu holidays and everything. So I really like that Kelly is, has this defiant attitude about it, that it's really important while also not knowing anything about it at all. Yes, except that she gets to wear like an outfit that has some sparkles on it.
我去假装我和我的家人是印度教节日专家等等更有趣的话。所以我真的很喜欢凯利对此有一种挑衅的态度，这真的很重要，同时也完全不知道它是什么。是的，除了她可以穿一件有亮片的衣服。
Yes, yeah, exactly. And the music part, she's really excited about that. Yeah. And Michael in the cold open, I mean, Mindy, I love whenever Steve would do an impression of us as our characters. And so Michael's like, well, if you ask Kelly, it's like, blah, blah, super fun.
是的，是的，完全正确。还有音乐部分，她对此真的很兴奋。是的。还有冷开场里的迈克尔，我是说，敏迪，我喜欢史蒂夫模仿我们作为角色的样子。所以迈克尔就像，好吧，如果你问凯利，就像，布拉布拉，超级有趣。
Blah, blah, blah. Yes, I know, and he didn't get to do that that much, right? Like I felt like that he didn't do impressions of us too, too much. When he did, it just got me so tickled. I know, it was so funny. I have a gazillion things I wanna say, Jenna, but go if you have something. Go, go, you go.
布拉布拉布拉。是的，我知道，他没能做太多，对吧？就像我觉得他模仿我们模仿得不多。当他模仿时，这让我很开心。我知道，这太有趣了。我有无数的事情想说，珍娜，但如果你有话要说就去吧。去吧，去吧，你去吧。
One of my favorite lines in this whole episode is this, how long have you been married to the cheerleader? And that was your dad. Oh my gosh. To this day, my dad gets checks from, he gets residual checks. It's like his, the thing he's the most proud of. Oh, from the office? Yes, from the office.
我在这一整集中最喜欢的台词之一是这个，你和那个啦啦队长结婚多久了？那是你爸爸。哦天哪。直到今天，我爸爸还会收到支票，他收到剩余支票。这就像他的，他最引以为豪的事情。哦，来自《办公室》？是的，来自《办公室》。
From the office, right? Yeah. And one time he was with my stepmom at Arowan and they got stopped and someone was like, you are in the office, weren't you? And that was like early when they were dating before they got married. And my dad was like, you are in the office, weren't you? And that was early when they were dating before they got married, and my dad was like, felt so cool about it. So, yeah. Oh, yeah, that was like some good street cred right there.
来自《办公室》，对吧？是的。有一次他和我的继母在Arowan，他们被拦住了，有人说，你在《办公室》里，不是吗？那是在他们约会早期，在他们结婚之前。我爸爸当时就像，你在《办公室》里，不是吗？那是在他们约会早期，在他们结婚之前，我爸爸当时就像，感觉很酷。所以，是的。哦，是的，那真是太有街头信誉了。
I mean, recognized. Yeah, completely. I just remember that that was like those episodes. You know, at the beginning of the season, it felt like one thing we did a lot was somehow we pulled out someone from the main cast and there was somebody somewhere else, and that was Stanford for that season.
我是说，被认出来了。是的，完全。我只是记得那些剧集。你知道，在赛季开始时，感觉我们做的一件事就是不知何故我们把主要演员中的某个人拉了出来，有某个人在别的地方，那个赛季就是斯坦福。
Yes. And it was one of those ones where I really liked the Stanford episodes. I think sometimes when we did that, it worked really well. Sometimes when we pulled them out, we were like, just come back. We just like want you back in the main cast. But that was a time where I felt like it worked pretty well. And I remember thinking because I was like at the beginning, I was like, what was like Ed and John doing? And I was like, oh, they weren't there.
是的。这是我真的很喜欢斯坦福剧集的其中之一。我想有时当我们这样做时，效果很好。有时当我们把他们拉出来时，我们就像，回来吧。我们只是想让你回到主要演员阵容中。但那是一个我觉得效果相当不错的时候。我记得当时想，因为我当时在开始时，我就想，埃德和约翰在做什么？我就想，哦，他们不在那里。
So it was fun to just, I forgot about that whole thing. And I remember what I really liked about Stanford was like, that was a really funny group of people there. Even the people that didn't have big parts, like in the Stanford branch. I just thought we nailed those prototypes or whatever. I was never bored when I had to go over there. No, it was so well done.
所以去那里很有趣，我忘了那整件事。我记得我真正喜欢斯坦福的是，那是一群非常有趣的人。即使是那些在斯坦福分部没有大角色的演员。我只是觉得我们钉住了那些原型之类的。当我要去那里时，我从不感到无聊。不，它做得太好了。
We talked a little bit about having over on the Scranton set, like Angela and I having a little bit of FOMO and jealousy of how much fun they were having over on Stanford because everybody was so funny. And also they would only have to work like one and a half days a week. Cause they're super relaxed and just like having the best time and then they got four days off. And we were, we were just like, hey. I forgot about that.
我们谈论了一点关于在斯克兰顿片场，就像安吉拉和我有一点FOMO（错失恐惧症）和嫉妒他们在斯坦福玩得有多开心，因为每个人都太有趣了。而且他们每周只需要工作一天半。因为他们超级放松，只是玩得最开心，然后他们有四天假。而我们，我们只是像，嘿。我忘了那个。
I forgot about that. Well, well Jenna, the best example of that was the Michael Scott paper company, which was like, which was like to me, one of my favorite arcs we've ever done. And I don't think I wrote any of the episodes for you guys there, but like it has, I think, that pairing of people, that group of people on their mission was like one of the times
我忘了那个。好吧，好吧珍娜，最好的例子就是迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司，那就像，那就像对我来说，我最喜欢的我们做过的弧线之一。我不认为我为你们写过那里的任何剧集，但它有，我想，那种人的配对，那群人在他们的任务中，就像其中一次
where I was like, wow, this is just like equally, if not more funny than like anything that's going. Wait, and that's when Idris Elba was, was that? Yeah. Well, I mean, I guess if you cut back to Idris Elba, you're doing fine. Yeah. I loved being in Michael Scott Paper Company. Oh my God. I kind of didn't want that arc to end. And Vikram, the four of you together. Oh my gosh. Yeah. Amazing. It was so, it was like, it could have been its own movie. Like, I know we're not talking about the Michael Scott Paper Company right now. We're talking about Diwali, but it felt
当时我就觉得，哇，这简直和正在播出的任何节目一样有趣，甚至更有趣。等等，那是伊德里斯·艾尔巴（Idris Elba）在的时候吗？是的。嗯，我是说，我想如果你切回伊德里斯·艾尔巴的镜头，那你就做得很好。是的。我喜欢在迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司（Michael Scott Paper Company）的那段时光。天哪。我真不想那个故事线结束。还有维克拉姆（Vikram），你们四个人在一起。天哪。是的。太棒了。那感觉就像，它完全可以拍成一部独立的电影。我知道我们现在不是在谈论迈克尔·斯科特造纸公司。我们在谈论排灯节（Diwali），但感觉
like it was his own Bad News Bears type movie. But you're right, Mindy. There were these pairings that would happen that were just as pure and beautiful as what was happening in Scranton. And I got the DVD box set and I watched the deleted scenes and there are so many scenes at Stanford that never made it in. And there's the character that's like, was always breastfeeding. Oh yeah, Hannah. Yes, Hannah would make Jim really uncomfortable.
就像是他自己的《少棒闯天下》（Bad News Bears）那样的电影。但你是对的，敏迪（Mindy）。当时确实出现了一些组合，它们和斯克兰顿（Scranton）发生的事情一样纯粹而美好。我买了DVD套装，看了删减片段，斯坦福（Stanford）有很多从未播出的场景。还有一个角色总是处于哺乳期。哦，是的，汉娜（Hannah）。是的，汉娜会让吉姆（Jim）感到非常不自在。
And then as far as this episode, I do have a question for you because I was texting with Rashida and she was like, this is the episode I was so worried everyone was gonna hate me because Jim and Karen have this sloppy make out out in the parking lot. Yeah. Like a tipsy make out.
至于这一集，我确实有个问题要问你，因为我当时在和拉什达（Rashida）发短信，她说：“这一集我非常担心大家会讨厌我，因为吉姆和凯伦（Karen）在停车场里有那种邋遢的亲热戏。”是的。就像那种醉醺醺的亲热。
It's not in the deleted scenes. It didn't even make that cut. And so- It was in the shooting draft. Oh yeah? Did Rashida, did you guys end up shooting that? Cause I was gonna ask about that too. When I was going, I have the shooting draft
它不在删减片段里。它甚至没能进入最终剪辑。所以——它在拍摄剧本里。哦，是吗？拉什达，你们最后拍了吗？因为我也想问这个。当我去看的时候，我有这一集的拍摄剧本
from this episode and I went back and I read it and I was like, wait, wait, Jim and Karen kiss? Yeah. They're kissing? I know. Why are they making out? But then it's nowhere in the episode and it's not in the deleted scenes.
从这一集开始，我回去读了它，然后我就想，等等，等等，吉姆和凯伦接吻了？是的。他们在接吻？我知道。他们为什么要亲热？但这一集里根本没有，删减片段里也没有。
Well, I have a memory, even though I was the writer on set, obviously, for the episode, I have zero memory of that. But I will say that one thing that we used to do, I felt a lot, was to write scripts that advance story and then what we'd notice when we only had 21 1 1⁄2 minutes to air an episode, that such, like a little went such a long way. Like if there is an attractive woman
嗯，我有段记忆，尽管我显然是这一集的现场编剧，但我对那段戏毫无印象。但我得说，我们过去常做的一件事，我觉得很多时候是这样，就是写一些推进故事的剧本，然后当我们发现只有21分半钟来播出这一集时，我们会注意到，一点点内容就能起到很大的作用。比如，如果有一个有吸引力的女性
who is working in the new environment and she seems to have some kind of rapport with Jim or together they're making fun of Andy, you're like, oh, that's interesting. Like that might be something. And so it felt like we were always like pulling back that stuff. Like Jenna, don't you feel like you shot a lot of stuff
在新的环境中工作，她似乎和吉姆很投缘，或者他们在一起取笑安迪（Andy），你就会觉得，哦，这很有趣。这可能有点什么。所以感觉我们总是会删减那些内容。比如珍娜（Jenna），你不觉得你和约翰（John）拍了很多
with John that was like, not like, cause you guys weren't like super flirty in those early seasons, like overtly flirty, but like that you'd watch it and you're like, oh, this was like, they used like less than I thought they would in terms of like showing your guys's like budding romance. Yes. And I would also add that there were some scenes where we would get in. I don't know if I would call it fights, but there were some like disagreements in certain episodes
不是那种，因为你们在早期几季里并不是特别调情，不是那种公开的调情，但你看了之后会觉得，哦，这就像，他们用的比我想象的要少，在展示你们那种萌芽中的浪漫方面。是的，我还要补充一点，有些场景我们确实会进入。我不知道是否该称之为争吵，但在某些剧集中确实有一些分歧
and they would pull back on those too and they would make them smaller. I wonder if it's interesting, it's just like for so much of the show in terms of romance, it was always like less is more, whereas for comedy, it was like, let's hoist up Tony Gardner onto the table. But for all that stuff, it was, yeah, just a little goes a long way. But the relationships were so finessed. I thought they were so smartly done.
他们也会删减那些内容，让它们变得更小。我觉得这很有趣，对于这部剧的大部分浪漫情节来说，总是“少即是多”，而对于喜剧，则是“让我们把托尼·加德纳（Tony Gardner）抬到桌子上”。但对于所有这些内容，是的，一点点就足够了。但这些关系处理得非常巧妙。我觉得它们做得非常聪明。
One of the things I remember really well about this episode was, again, like it's such a time capsule of like 2006 or whatever, because the love interest, he wasn't really love interest, but there is an Indian character who my parents preferred to Ryan. That was like a very small part of it. And it was played by this writer, Vali Chandra Shekran, who was kind of a friend of the writers on the show, but not an actor, just a guy, like a guy we knew. There was a real sort of casualness to our show of like, we're just kind of putting it together. Yeah, We probably shot this, this is season three, right? That for Diwali, it was,
关于这一集，我记得很清楚的一件事是，它就像是2006年左右的时间胶囊，因为那个恋爱对象，他其实算不上恋爱对象，但有一个印度角色，我父母比瑞安（Ryan）更喜欢他。那只是其中很小的一部分。它是由编剧瓦利·钱德拉·谢克兰（Vali Chandra Shekran）扮演的，他算是剧组编剧的朋友，但不是演员，只是我们认识的一个人。我们的剧有一种真正的随意感，就像我们只是把它拼凑在一起。是的，我们可能拍了这个，这是第三季，对吧？对于排灯节，它是，
we knew that season two had done well. I don't, we'd been nominated probably at this point when we were shooting. We had. We'd been nominated, but we didn't know. So I felt like now I felt like at the beginning of season three, when we started shooting, we started feeling like a little bit more like, okay, we're not going to just get canceled or something.
我们知道第二季表现不错。我不确定，我们拍摄时可能已经获得了提名。我们确实获得了。我们获得了提名，但我们不知道。所以我感觉现在，在第三季开始拍摄时，我们开始感觉多了一点，好吧，我们不会只是被取消之类的。
Because I remember so much stress earlier on thinking like, it's hard to enjoy a show as much when you're like, is this even going to last? And I do remember being able to enjoy things a little bit more starting like at the beginning of season three. Sorry, I just keep going off of because I don't get to talk about the office that much. I just am talking really like, like holistically about the show instead of just about this episode. But don't worry, we're going to break down this whole episode and like get into the nitty gritty of it. So this can be your office memories. There's no prescription for what we talk about. Yeah. Okay. Cool. Greg was on to talk about
因为我记得早期的压力很大，觉得当你还在想“这节目能持续下去吗”的时候，很难去享受它。我确实记得从第三季开始，我能更多地享受这些事情了。抱歉，我一直在跑题，因为我没机会谈论《办公室》（The Office）太多。我只是在非常全面地谈论这部剧，而不是只谈这一集。但别担心，我们会剖析这一整集，深入探讨细节。所以这可以是你的《办公室》回忆。我们谈论什么没有限制。是的。好的。酷。格雷格（Greg）来谈论
booze cruise and we just, we went everywhere, you know? But that's, it's such a special chapter in all of our lives. I think it's hard to compartmentalize it to one episode. It's such a big part of us. You know, one of the things I remember a lot about doing The Office was we didn't realize as writers how rare it was for Greg to just say, okay, well, I'm just gonna give one person
《游船》（Booze Cruise），我们聊了很多，你知道吗？但这是我们所有人生命中非常特别的一章。我觉得很难把它局限在某一集里。它是我们很大的一部分。你知道，我记得做《办公室》时的一件事是，我们作为编剧没有意识到，格雷格只给一个人机会是多么罕见
from the writer's world on set, and that's just going to be the writer of the episode. Some people do that now, but it's usually like an upper level writer. So it's your job to make sure that the intention of Alliance is being corrected, give alts, answer questions from the actors. And I was a story editor when I did this.
从现场的编剧世界里，那个人就是这一集的编剧。现在有些人会这样做，但通常是高级编剧。所以你的工作是确保“联盟”（Alliance）的意图得到纠正，提供替代方案，回答演员的问题。我做这一集时是故事编辑。
And I remember like that was pretty stressful, I think. Like, I remember being on the set, because Miguel Arteta was not one of our directors that we had all the time. And so I remember feeling like, is this, like, am I being too, like, on set? Because we're on location a lot for this episode. I was like, am I too much in his hair?
我记得那压力很大，我想。我记得在片场，因为米格尔·阿特塔（Miguel Arteta）不是我们一直用的导演。所以我记得我感觉，我是不是在片场太活跃了？因为这一集我们有很多外景。我当时想，我是不是太碍事了？
Is he going to yell at me? Because I think season one, I was never alone for Hot Girl. Like I think Howard and Greg were there for almost all the shooting because it was a lot. I think one of the last ones we shot. But for this one, it was just like, go manage set, answer all Indian questions and make sure it's hilarious and do all alts. It's so funny you say that Mindy, because my impression of you as the writer on set was just always that you were one of my favorites. Really? That's so nice.
他会对我大喊大叫吗？因为我觉得第一季，拍《辣妹》（Hot Girl）时我从没一个人。我想霍华德（Howard）和格雷格几乎都在拍摄现场，因为内容很多。我想这是我们拍的最后几集之一。但对于这一集，就像是“去管理片场，回答所有关于印度的问题，确保它非常搞笑，并做所有的替代方案”。敏迪，你说这话太搞笑了，因为我对你作为现场编剧的印象一直是你是我最喜欢的人之一。真的吗？那太好了。
Oh, yes. Mostly because you were so up to laugh. Like, you found... I always felt like you found everyone hilarious. Oh, my God. You seemed to like everything. You had the best alts. So you would sort of throw out ideas, maybe based on something you watched us do.
哦，是的。主要是因为你太爱笑了。就像，你发现……我一直觉得你觉得每个人都很搞笑。天哪。你似乎喜欢一切。你有最好的替代方案。所以你会抛出一些想法，也许是基于你看到我们做的事情。
You'd be like, oh my gosh, oh my gosh. Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. You have to do that again, do that again. And then what do you think about saying this? And it was like, oh my gosh, it was just like this uplifting, exciting. That's so nice. Oh, I loved it.
你会说，哦天哪，哦天哪。好的，等等，等等，等等，等等，等等。你必须再做一次，再做一次。然后你觉得说这个怎么样？这就像，哦天哪，这就像是一种令人振奋的、令人兴奋的。那太好了。哦，我喜欢它。
I loved it. We've talked a lot about that. Jen Salado was very similar as well. Well, Jen, you couldn't get, she just would laugh the whole time. We'd actually have to throw her off because she would ruin takes. Yeah. Yeah, I thought, you know, there's this thing that we would do on the show where when a cut would come out, the director's cut, and I've never seen it on any other show, we would all gather and watch it together in the writer's room.
我喜欢它。我们谈论了很多。珍·萨拉多（Jen Salado）也很相似。嗯，珍，你无法阻止她，她会一直笑。我们实际上不得不把她赶走，因为她会毁掉拍摄。是的。是的，我想，你知道，我们在剧中有件事，当剪辑出来时，导演剪辑版，我在其他任何节目中都没见过，我们会聚在一起在编剧室观看。
And director's cuts, famously, in other shows, like make you want to kill yourself. They're usually so bad. But the quality was so good because the cast was so good. And so I remember it was like my favorite time we could interrupt all of our work and just go into the little living room area of our writers room and watch. I mean, I was such a fan of the show. I watched almost every cut of every episode and then I would watch it live too.
而导演剪辑版，众所周知，在其他节目中，会让你想自杀。它们通常太糟糕了。但质量非常好，因为演员阵容太棒了。所以我记得那是我最喜欢的时光，我们可以中断所有的工作，走进编剧室的小客厅区域观看。我是说，我是这部剧的忠实粉丝。我看了几乎每一集的每一个剪辑，然后我也会看直播。
And I didn't realize how unusual that is for somebody who works on a show. Most people do it and then a lot of actors don't even watch it when it airs. But I, I really was such a huge fan of the show and a lot of times in those conference room scenes like I'd have like no lines or one line or something in these four page scenes and to me it was like going to Second City and just watching everyone just be so funny and it just be for free and you'd be in this like freezing cold room and there'd be snacks every two hours. And I was like, how could this be better? It felt like such an abundance of riches.
我没意识到这对一个在节目组工作的人来说是多么不寻常。大多数人做完就完了，很多演员甚至在播出时都不看。但我，我真的是这部剧的超级粉丝，很多时候在那些会议室场景里，我可能没有台词，或者只有一句台词，在这些四页的场景里，对我来说，这就像去第二城（Second City）看每个人都那么搞笑，而且是免费的，你会在这个冷得要命的房间里，每两个小时就有零食。我就想，这怎么能更好呢？这感觉就像是极其丰富的财富。
I just loved sitting and watching everyone in character, just reacting. Mindy, I remember one time you were on stage and BJ and you guys were at reception by Jenna and you guys were talking and I walked up and you were having a conversation about some type of like economics. It was like some kind of like you'd you'd expanded economics and I walked up and I was like, I'm gonna go over here.
我只是喜欢坐着看每个人扮演角色，只是做出反应。敏迪，我记得有一次你在舞台上，BJ和你，你们在珍娜的接待处，你们在交谈，我走过去，你们在谈论某种经济学。就像某种你扩展了经济学，我走过去，我说，我要去那边。
I was just like, they are two of the smartest people I ever met. And I'm gonna hard pivot. Wait, BJ and I were gonna hard pivot and back away. Wait, BJ and I were talking about economics. We weren't fighting. I'm so surprised. Oh no, it was a heated discussion. You were on opposite sides.
我当时就像，他们是我见过最聪明的两个人。我要来个急转弯。等等，BJ和我要来个急转弯然后退后。等等，BJ和我在谈论经济学。我们没有吵架。我很惊讶。哦不，那是一场激烈的讨论。你们站在对立面。
That is so funny. 100%. That is so funny. Well, I just, I remember you and Paul and BJ as a little trio, probably because you were the writers who were with the actors. So between takes, you guys would always kind of huddle up and talk like story ideas and like what's happening in the writers' room.
那太搞笑了。100%。那太搞笑了。嗯，我只是，我记得你、保罗（Paul）和BJ作为一个小三人组，可能是因为你们是和演员在一起的编剧。所以在拍摄间隙，你们总是会聚在一起谈论故事创意，以及编剧室里发生了什么。
And so you were having to kind of manage two jobs at once. And I used to like hover around you guys and eavesdrop and just like hope you would invite me in to your hilarious conference. Really? Yes, some of my favorite memories are listening to you guys discuss story and character and pitch jokes to each other in between scenes. Well, that's so funny.
所以你们不得不同时处理两份工作。我过去喜欢在你们周围徘徊，偷听，只是希望你们能邀请我加入你们搞笑的会议。真的吗？是的，我最喜欢的一些回忆就是听你们讨论故事和角色，在场景之间互相抛出笑话。嗯，那太搞笑了。
Cause I felt like when we were in the annex, we, you know, we were, the writers were in the annex. I'm sure you guys have talked about this many times, but we were in the annex, obviously, because then we could go be the writer's room and we wouldn't have to were in the annex, I'm sure you guys have talked about this many times, but we were in the annex, obviously, because then we could go be in the writer's room and we wouldn't have to be in some of the big group scenes. But I remember also thinking like, but I want to be in the big group scenes.
因为我觉得当我们在附楼（Annex）时，我们，你知道，我们是，编剧们在附楼。我相信你们已经谈论过很多次了，但我们在附楼，显然，因为那样我们就可以去成为编剧室，我们就不必在附楼了，我相信你们已经谈论过很多次了，但我们在附楼，显然，因为那样我们就可以去成为编剧室，我们就不必在一些大型集体场景中。但我记得我也在想，但我想要在大型集体场景中。
Like, I, like, those were the funnest scenes to watch when like, you know, Dwight would run in and be like, everyone to the roof. Like, we just were left out of those scenes, like, about Diwali. So here's a couple of things that I felt were maybe interesting to say, which was that we only cast my parents in it,
就像，那些是最有趣的场景，当，你知道，德怀特（Dwight）跑进来大喊“所有人到屋顶去”的时候。就像，我们被排除在那些场景之外，关于排灯节。所以这里有几件事我觉得可能很有趣，那就是我们只让我的父母出演了，
which seems just like a complete act of nepotism and favoritism because we had auditioned the parts and Greg had felt that the actors we had found of that age group, like the late 50s, early 60s, were like a little bit too either theatrical for that style of acting on our show or too stilted because they had no acting experience. Now, I'm the first to say that my parents' acting was also very stilted, but he was like, at least they bear some familial resemblance to you.
这看起来完全是裙带关系和偏袒，因为我们试镜了这些角色，格雷格觉得我们找到的那个年龄段的演员，比如50多岁末、60多岁初，要么对于我们剧中的那种表演风格来说有点太戏剧化了，要么因为他们没有表演经验而太生硬。现在，我第一个承认我父母的表演也非常生硬，但他觉得，至少他们和你长得有点像。
So we'll just put them in there. And I don't know if you guys remember this, but I remember going into it. My mom was like, had this energy of like, hi, I'm just like gonna be so much better than your father. Like, I just know like neither of them in any acting. She was a doctor, he was an architect, but she had this sense like coming over that she's like, I just hope that you give me the most lines
所以我们就把他们放进去了。我不知道你们是否还记得，但我记得当时。我妈妈有一种能量，就像，“嗨，我肯定会比你爸爸好得多。”就像，我只是知道他们俩都没有任何表演经验。她是医生，他是建筑师，但她有一种感觉，过来时她就像，“我只是希望你能给我最多的台词，
because I'm just naturally better on camera and like, it's gonna be good. But then Miguel like fell in love with my dad. Like he was like, we have to give him more lines. Like he's killing it. And you guys remember like, this is the show where if anyone ever fell for anyone, Troy L. Underbridge, who was like just kind of like,
因为我天生在镜头前表现更好，而且，这会很棒。”但后来米格尔爱上了我爸爸。就像他说的，“我们必须给他更多台词。他表现得太棒了。”你们还记得吗，这是那种如果有人爱上任何人，特洛伊·L·安德布里奇（Troy L. Underbridge），他就像是……
if anyone was interesting to a director in the wrong reasons, like just cause like, oh my God, like I just love that guy's look, they could recur on the show for a long time. And I remember being like, I cannot have my dad and my mom come back here like ever again to do this kind of thing. So I remember Miguel Arteta was like,
如果有人因为错误的原因对导演来说很有趣，就像，“哦天哪，我就是喜欢那个家伙的样子”，他们可以在剧里反复出现很长时间。我记得我当时想，我不能让我爸爸妈妈再来这里做这种事了。所以我记得米格尔·阿特塔说，
hey, do you think we can add your dad to the background of like another scene? And I was like, no, we can't. I was gonna ask you what it was like for you to have them on set. I was, I don't know if you guys feel this way, but you don't really, Ange, because like your family, you guys are so tight,
“嘿，你觉得我们可以把你爸爸加到另一个场景的背景里吗？”我说，“不，我们不能。”我本来想问你让他们在片场是什么感觉。我不知道你们是否也有这种感觉，但你没有，安吉（Ange），因为你的家人，你们关系太紧密了，
so I don't think you have this. But I did not feel so established on the show as a writer or as an actor that I felt so comfortable having them there. Like I was really worried about it or as an actor that I felt so comfortable having them there. I was really worried about it seeming unprofessional or just that they would tell boring stories to people and Jenna would be like, hey, can you get this guy away from me? Tell an AD, I can't hear the story anymore.
所以我认为你没有这种感觉。但我作为编剧或演员在剧组里并没有感到那么稳固，以至于我觉得让他们在那里很自在。我真的很担心，或者作为演员，我觉得让他们在那里很自在。我真的很担心这看起来不专业，或者他们会给别人讲无聊的故事，珍娜会说，“嘿，你能把这家伙从我身边带走吗？告诉助理导演，我不想再听这个故事了。”
Can you please? So I think I was worried and I think I told them like, don't like talk to people at craft services for too long. Like just say hi and answer questions, but don't like launch into, you know, other stuff. But that was one thing. I thought they were delightful. We were so excited to have them and they were so cute. Mindy, they were so cute.
你能吗？所以我认为我很担心，我想我告诉他们，“不要在餐点服务处和人聊太久。打个招呼回答问题就行，但不要开始讲其他东西。”但那是一件事。我觉得他们很可爱。我们很高兴有他们，他们太可爱了。敏迪，他们太可爱了。
Well, they're both like five foot four. They're just like both like little, they're both little people. Yeah, they're my like five foot four. They're just like both like little, they're both little people. Yeah, they're my people. I remember your mom complimented my blouse and I remember it. That's nice. She liked the color on me and I was like,
嗯，他们俩都只有五英尺四英寸高。他们就像两个小个子，他们都是小个子。是的，他们是我的……他们只有五英尺四英寸高。他们就像两个小个子，他们都是小个子。是的，他们是我的家人。我记得你妈妈夸奖了我的衬衫，我记得。那太好了。她喜欢我穿的颜色，我就说，
oh, thanks so much. I don't know, I thought they were delightful. And by the way, I thought their acting was amazing. Thank you. I was watching them and that scene was Steve and I was like, they are killing it. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh, your mom ate him up.
“哦，太感谢了。”我不知道，我觉得他们很可爱。顺便说一句，我觉得他们的表演太棒了。谢谢。我看着他们，那个场景是和史蒂夫（Steve）一起的，我就想，他们表现得太棒了。哦天哪。哦天哪，你妈妈完全抢了戏。
Like that was amazing. They were, I cannot believe, because that was at the time where I was like, I'd like to have a scene with Steve, you know, like it felt so special. And here they are. They were like, he's at a crossroads with Carol and my dad is like, you should be with her. I don't forget exactly what he said, but I remember being like, this is kind of a juicy scene. But you know, there's a nice little story because like, I should be with her. I don't forget exactly what he said, but I remember being like, this is kind of a juicy scene.
那太棒了。他们是，我简直不敢相信，因为那是我当时想，“我想和史蒂夫演一场戏”的时候，你知道，这感觉太特别了。而他们就在这里。他们就像，他正处于和卡罗尔（Carol）的十字路口，我爸爸说，“你应该和她在一起。”我不记得他确切说了什么，但我记得我当时想，这是一个相当精彩的场景。但你知道，这是一个不错的小故事，因为……
But you know, there's a nice little story, because like, I feel like Pam stories had such an emotional impact, but they often didn't have like lots and lots of like lines to them, but they always were so impactful. I was like, I thought your little story in this one was pretty sweet, Jenna. Like, it was like, you know, you didn't really want to go,
我觉得帕姆（Pam）的故事有很大的情感冲击力，但它们通常没有很多很多的台词，但它们总是那么有影响力。我当时想，我觉得你这一集里的小故事很甜，珍娜。就像，你知道，你其实不想去，
and then you end up having like, I don't know. I thought it was like a nice. I like those kinds of Pam stories. I liked it, too. I also I was really struck by how incredibly good looking David Denman was in this episode. I was like, Pam, Pam, stop for a second. Open your eyes, see what's in front of you. And just maybe I mean, maybe just revisit that for one night, Pam your eyes, see what's in front of you, and just maybe, I mean
然后你最终有了，我不知道。我觉得这是一个不错的。我喜欢那种帕姆的故事。我也喜欢。我还被大卫·丹曼（David Denman）在这一集里看起来有多帅所震撼。我当时想，帕姆，帕姆，停一下。睁开眼睛，看看你面前的是什么。也许，我的意思是，也许只是为了那一晚重新考虑一下，帕姆，看看你面前的是什么，也许，我的意思是
maybe just revisit that for one night, Pam. It's one night. That's what, that's what I was thinking the whole time. Yeah, David Denman. He was also really tan. He was really, like I don't know what David was doing in his real life, but he's super tan. Yeah. In one shape. It was good to show that Roy had good qualities and was good looking too, so that you weren't just like, what the hell? Like, why is it not? It's good that he was, yeah, David Duhman is a legitimate smoke show. He doesn't get enough credit.
也许只是为了那一晚重新考虑一下，帕姆。就一晚。那就是我当时一直在想的。是的，大卫·丹曼。他当时也很黑。他真的很，我不知道大卫在现实生活中在做什么，但他超级黑。是的。状态很好。展示罗伊（Roy）有优点而且长得帅也很好，这样你就不会觉得，“到底怎么回事？为什么不是？”他长得帅很好，是的，大卫·丹曼是个合法的帅哥。他得到的赞誉不够多。
Yeah. Guys, this was so much fun. Now that I've done it and you guys made me feel so welcome, I would love to come back and do another one sometime. We will have you back anytime, Mindy. I really, I'm sure you already did this and talked about it with somebody else on the show, but if we ever do Branch Wars, Jenna,
是的。伙计们，这太有趣了。既然我已经做到了，而且你们让我感到如此受欢迎，我很乐意以后再回来做一次。我们随时欢迎你回来，敏迪。我真的，我肯定你已经做过这件事并和剧组里的其他人谈过了，但如果我们以后做《分部战争》（Branch Wars），珍娜，
I have so many funny memories of it. Like, one thing I remember really well was, normally you'd sit in a conference room type scene and Michael would be the person that would just be so funny that you felt like, I'm going to break and die. And I remember I was not, I was on set with you because I'd written the episode, but I was not obviously at the branch
我有很多关于它的有趣回忆。比如，我记得很清楚的一件事是，通常你会坐在会议室类型的场景里，迈克尔会是那个让你觉得“我要笑场死掉了”的人。我记得我没有，我和你一起在片场，因为我写了那一集，但我显然不在分部
as a character, I wasn't there. And I remember when you had to take over for Michael because he had like a breakdown, that was like some of the funniest moments of any episode I'd ever seen. Like you in front of like just eating it and having to be like this valiant assistant and friend to Michael.
作为一个角色，我不在那里。我记得当你不得不接替迈克尔，因为他崩溃了，那是我见过的任何剧集中最有趣的时刻之一。就像你在前面，完全搞砸了，不得不成为迈克尔那种英勇的助手和朋友。
I remember that and I also remember Michael cutting a piece of her sweater off. Those were my two favorite moments of that episode. Thank you, Mindy. I had a great time. Mindy, thank you so much. It was such a joy to see you. Thank you so much. It was really fun joy to see you. Thank you so much.
我记得那个，我也记得迈克尔剪掉了她毛衣的一块。那是我那一集里最喜欢的两个时刻。谢谢你，敏迪。我玩得很开心。敏迪，非常感谢你。见到你真是太高兴了。非常感谢你。见到你真是太高兴了。非常感谢你。
It was really fun. Great to see you. And yeah, guys, good. I mean, I was going to say good luck, but you don't need good luck. You're already, this is the number one podcast ever. But stop it. By the way, speaking of, I can't believe legally,
这真的很有趣。很高兴见到你。是的，伙计们，好的。我是说，我本来想说祝你们好运，但你们不需要好运。你们已经是，这是有史以来排名第一的播客。但别说了。顺便说一句，说到这个，我简直不敢相信，从法律上讲，
well, I'm three, I'm so excited. Thank you. We love you so much, Mindy. OK, bye. Bye, Mindy. Bye. Thank you. We love you so much, Mindy. Okay, bye. Bye, Mindy. Bye. And we are back.
嗯，我三岁了，我很兴奋。谢谢。我们非常爱你，敏迪。好的，再见。再见，敏迪。再见。谢谢。我们非常爱你，敏迪。好的，再见。再见，敏迪。再见。我们回来了。
Mindy Kaling. So fun. Please come back. That was so great. We have to have her back. I know. All right, ladies, should we break down this episode? We talked a little bit about this cold open with Mindy. We open in the office.
敏迪·卡灵（Mindy Kaling）。太有趣了。请再回来。那太棒了。我们必须让她回来。我知道。好了，女士们，我们要剖析这一集吗？我们和敏迪谈了一点关于这个冷开场的内容。我们在办公室开场。
Kelly is helping Ryan with his curta and Michael enters and he starts laughing at it. He calls it a dress, right? But then Pam and Kelly gush about how handsome Ryan looks and Michael suddenly wishes that he had one too. He's such a child. He's like, how come you didn't get me one? I think you can see Mindy starting to break when he says that.
凯利（Kelly）正在帮瑞安（Ryan）穿他的库尔塔（kurta），迈克尔进来了，他开始嘲笑它。他称之为裙子，对吧？但后来帕姆和凯利对瑞安看起来有多帅赞不绝口，迈克尔突然希望自己也有一件。他真是个孩子。他就像，“你怎么没给我买一件？”我想你可以看到迈克尔说那话时，敏迪开始笑场了。
And I wondered if that was an improvised line, Jenna. No, it's in the script. Because I feel like you can see Mindy starting to do that break that she does. Like she was taken by surprise? Yeah. No, that's just Mindy breaking because you said words, which is what Mindy used to like to do. Well, now we have a party planning committee scene. You guys, we lived for these. We got so tickled whenever there was one in a script. I find it
我很好奇那是不是即兴台词，珍娜。不，剧本里有的。因为我觉得你可以看到敏迪开始做她那种笑场。就像她被吓了一跳？是的。不，那只是敏迪因为你说了那些话而笑场，这是敏迪过去喜欢做的事情。好了，现在我们有一个派对策划委员会的场景。伙计们，我们为这些场景而活。每当剧本里有这个，我们都会感到非常高兴。我发现
fascinating that in this party planning committee scene, it is Ryan, Meredith, Pam, Angela, and Phyllis, and they are discussing who's gonna carpool with who. There's a chart. Clearly they couldn't plan this party. They were invited guests. So they had to have something to plan. So they're planning carpools. This is what Phyllis wrote on the dry erase board.
在这个派对策划委员会的场景中，有瑞安、梅雷迪思（Meredith）、帕姆、安吉拉（Angela）和菲利斯（Phyllis），他们在讨论谁和谁拼车。有一张图表。显然他们无法策划这个派对。他们是被邀请的客人。所以他们必须策划点什么。所以他们在策划拼车。这就是菲利斯写在白板上的。
In Bob's Yukon, and she was very proud to say that he had a Yukon. In Bob's Yukon would be Phyllis, Stanley, Angela, Kevin, and Pam. In Meredith's minivan would be Meredith, Darryl, Lonnie, Creed, Ryan, and Kelly. Now, who is missing from the carpool? Oscar, he's on leave. Michael and Dwight. Who's riding with Michael and Dwight? They're on their own, I guess. Yeah, good question. Well, I guess Michael and Carol are going to go together,
在鲍勃（Bob）的育空（Yukon）车里，她很自豪地说他有一辆育空。在鲍勃的育空车里会有菲利斯、斯坦利（Stanley）、安吉拉、凯文（Kevin）和帕姆。在梅雷迪思的迷你面包车里会有梅雷迪思、达里尔（Darryl）、朗尼（Lonnie）、克里德（Creed）、瑞安和凯利。现在，拼车里少了谁？奥斯卡（Oscar），他在休假。迈克尔和德怀特。谁和迈克尔和德怀特一起坐车？我想他们是自己走。是的，好问题。嗯，我想迈克尔和卡罗尔会一起去，
but how did Dwight get there? He's solo. He's solo. But I want you guys to know there is a fantastic deleted scene. There's an extension of this party planning committee scene. And it's so funny because Angela doesn't want anyone to go. And I actually have a talking head where it sort of sets up why I'm so against Diwali. And it's not really about Diwali. It's because I think Dwight might still have a
但德怀特是怎么去的？他一个人。他一个人。但我希望你们知道有一个很棒的删减片段。这个派对策划委员会场景有一个延伸。这太搞笑了，因为安吉拉不想让任何人去。我实际上有一个谈话头（talking head），它解释了为什么我如此反对排灯节。这其实不是关于排灯节。这是因为我觉得德怀特可能还对凯利有
thing for Kelly or maybe there'll be someone else there he might be interested in. So I really have this attitude that listen, I actually have this line where I say certain people in this office are a little too obsessed with things from India. Yes. So she's jealous. And that's really her filter through all of this. That's why she's so salty all the way through. And then, Jenna, what I love is she's
意思，或者可能还有其他人他可能感兴趣。所以我真的有这种态度，听着，我实际上有句台词说“办公室里有些人对来自印度的事情太着迷了”。是的。所以她在嫉妒。这就是她贯穿始终的滤镜。这就是为什么她一直那么刻薄。然后，珍娜，我喜欢的是她
trying to talk people out of going. And Ryan was like, well, Kelly's kind of into it. I thought we could go. And then he's like, I don't care. Actually, we can bail's kind of into it. I thought we could go. And then he's like, I don't care, actually. We can bail. I don't care. Ryan was like, you guys want me to bail? Fine.
试图劝说人们不要去。瑞安说，嗯，凯利有点感兴趣。我想我们可以去。然后他说，我不在乎。其实，我们可以不去。我不在乎。瑞安说，你们想让我不去？好吧。
We actually got a lot of mail wondering why Angela was so salty about this festival. And so I'm really glad you shared that deleted scene, because there was this whole extra storyline element that it's you. And I think you kind of see it a little bit in the scene where Pam is telling Kelly she might not go and this and that and your head has popped up. Oh yeah. Behind that partition and you are a little jealous when Dwight with such
我们确实收到了很多邮件，想知道为什么安吉拉对这个节日这么刻薄。所以我很高兴你分享了那个删减片段，因为有一个完整的额外故事元素，那就是你。我想你在帕姆告诉凯利她可能不去等等的场景中也能看出来，你的头冒出来了。哦是的。在那个隔板后面，当你听到德怀特用那种
authority says he's single he's not seeing anyone. Yes. Because Kelly suggests maybe Pam go with Dwight if she doesn't want to go alone. And she's like, you're single, right Dwight? And Dwight's like, oh yeah, I'm totally single. And I think that's you see that little jealousy right there from Angela like, oh, don't like it. There's deleted scenes that really sort of play out this Dwight Angela storyline and her jealousy and how it resolves itself.
权威的语气说他是单身，他没和任何人约会时，你有点嫉妒。是的。因为凯利建议如果帕姆不想一个人去，也许可以和德怀特一起去。她说，“你是单身，对吧德怀特？”德怀特说，“哦是的，我完全单身。”我想这就是你看到的安吉拉的那种嫉妒，“哦，不喜欢。”有一些删减片段确实演绎了这个德怀特和安吉拉的故事线，以及她的嫉妒和它是如何解决的。
But that's what was going on for Angela Martin. So Michael gets aware of the fact that people might not be as enthusiastic about the Stowallee Festival as he would like. He says he thinks it's because people are just ignorant about other cultures. And he really does not want to be embarrassed by everyone's ignorance in front of his girlfriend, Carol.
但这就是安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）当时的情况。所以迈克尔意识到人们可能不像他希望的那样对排灯节充满热情。他说他认为这是因为人们对其他文化太无知了。他真的不想在女朋友卡罗尔面前因为大家的无知而感到尴尬。
Yeah, so he's got to educate everyone. So this means we're all going in the conference room. Yes. Once again, where does Michael get these posters? It feels last minute, but yet he has all these posters. Does he send white on a mad dash? There's all kinds of posters once we get in the conference room.
是的，所以他必须教育大家。这意味着我们都要去会议室。是的。再一次，迈克尔从哪儿弄来的这些海报？感觉像是最后一分钟，但他却有所有的海报。他是不是让德怀特去疯狂抢购了？我们一进会议室就有各种各样的海报。
It's so true. And when he starts showing us this slideshow, you notice how there's a photo of Michael and Carol kissing. Awkward. That accidentally makes its way into this presentation. Yeah, well then he passes out the Kama Sutra to the employees. And remember Angela, that was,
太真实了。当他开始给我们看幻灯片时，你注意到有一张迈克尔和卡罗尔接吻的照片。尴尬。那张照片意外地出现在了演示文稿中。是的，然后他把《爱经》（Kama Sutra）分发给员工。还记得安吉拉，那是，
those were like little booklets that Phil Shea had to put together and print of all these Kamasutra positions, and they were blurred out for television, but they were not blurred out in real life. We're all like, we're all sitting in the room as actors, and we get these little booklets. And I remember being totally like, oh, oh, wow. Okay. Of course, Kevin says this is the best meeting they've ever had. And I remember being totally like, oh, oh wow, okay. Of course, Kevin says this is the best meeting
那些是菲尔·谢（Phil Shea）不得不整理并打印的小册子，上面有所有这些《爱经》姿势，它们在电视上被模糊处理了，但在现实生活中没有。我们都像，我们作为演员坐在房间里，我们拿到了这些小册子。我记得我完全是，“哦，哦，哇。好的。”当然，凯文说这是他们参加过的最好的会议。我记得我完全是，“哦，哦哇，好的。当然，凯文说这是他们参加过的最好的会议。”
they've ever had. The best one. If you guys get a chance and rewatch the scene, at the end, Toby takes away the Kama Sutra. And I want you to look at Phyllis's face because she makes an expression like she's really bummed out to lose the book. Oh my gosh, I missed that.
最好的一个。如果你们有机会重看这一集，在最后，托比（Toby）拿走了《爱经》。我希望你们看看菲利斯的脸，因为她做了一个表情，好像因为丢了书而非常沮丧。天哪，我错过了那个。
Made me laugh. I can't Oh my gosh, I missed that. I can't wait to go back and see that. Well, Angela, should we talk a little bit about what's going on in Stanford? You mean with Josh Porter's biker shorts and his fancy bike and Jim and his clunky bike with a big basket, what's happening, Jim? What's going on? Well, Jim has started biking to work.
让我笑了。我不能……天哪，我错过了那个。我迫不及待想回去看看。嗯，安吉拉，我们谈谈斯坦福那边发生了什么吧？你是说乔什·波特（Josh Porter）的骑行短裤和他的花哨自行车，还有吉姆和他的笨重自行车以及大篮子，发生了什么，吉姆？发生了什么？嗯，吉姆开始骑自行车上班了。
Just like Josh. He says, I'm gonna save gas money. It keeps me in shape. He did not anticipate how sweaty he would be. That talking head is so funny, how much sweat they put on him. Angela, do you remember how they used to make us sweaty when you have to be sweaty?
就像乔什一样。他说，“我要省油钱。这让我保持身材。”他没预料到自己会出那么多汗。那个谈话头太搞笑了，他们在他身上放了多少汗。安吉拉，你还记得他们过去是怎么让我们出汗的吗，当你必须出汗的时候？
They spray you. Yeah, they would either spray you with like a bottle that you would mist spray you with like a bottle that you would mist your plants with, or they would spray you with like those Evian Mist sprays, and they have to like spritz you under the arms, but then they'd have to come and do it like between every take because it would dry, but then sometimes they would put like baby oil around like your hairline and then spray you so it would look especially sweaty. I'm just giving everybody a little inside info on how you make an actor sweaty. You can try it at home.
他们喷你。是的，他们要么用那种瓶子，那种你用来喷植物的瓶子喷你，要么用那种依云（Evian）喷雾喷你，他们必须在腋下喷，但他们必须在每次拍摄之间都来做，因为它会干，但有时他们会在你的发际线周围涂上婴儿油，然后喷你，这样看起来会特别出汗。我只是给每个人一点关于如何让演员出汗的内幕信息。你们可以在家试试。
Jenna, I'm just laughing at how many times you just said sweaty. Sweaty. Sweaty. All right. So now at four minutes, 23 seconds, Sam, will you play Mustang? Flirty Karen. Flirty Karen. That's my mom, Bertie Kinsey. Flirty Karen. Karen says, hey, nice basket. Ever since the whole chips incident, she's smitten. Yep. So then Josh comes over and gives Karen the company
珍娜，我只是在笑你刚才说了多少次“出汗”。出汗。出汗。好了。现在在4分23秒，萨姆，你能播放野马（Mustang）吗？调情的凯伦。调情的凯伦。那是我的妈妈，伯蒂·金西（Bertie Kinsey）。调情的凯伦。凯伦说，“嘿，不错的篮子。”自从薯片事件以来，她就迷上了他。是的。然后乔什过来给了凯伦公司
credit card because they have to work late and they're allowed to buy dinner. But he says, you know, no more than $20 a person this time. This time, $20 a person? We shot this in 2006. Is there a meal out there that you order that's more than $20 a person? Hey, maybe there's a reason Stanford doesn't make it. I mean, my gosh. I don't know. Maybe I just don't eat at very fancy places for my takeout, but I feel like I would be challenged to order a meal for more than $20 a person in 2006. Yeah, especially like late at night in Scranton. What are they getting? You know, like Thai food. I know. Exactly. This is not difficult. Andy, though, busts out some Jägermeister.
信用卡，因为他们必须加班，他们可以买晚餐。但他说了，“这次每人不超过20美元。”这次，每人20美元？我们2006年拍的。外面有每人超过20美元的餐点吗？嘿，也许斯坦福没能坚持下去是有原因的。我是说，天哪。我不知道。也许我只是不吃很贵的餐点，但我觉得在2006年，每人点超过20美元的餐点对我来说是个挑战。是的，特别是在斯克兰顿的深夜。他们点了什么？你知道，比如泰国菜。我知道。完全正确。这并不难。不过，安迪拿出了野格酒（Jägermeister）。
He's got other plans. He's ready to party. Ed Helms's face when he holds up that Jägermeister bottle and the shot glasses is hilarious. You get a window into who Andy was in college and you're like, oh, buddy. Well, back in Scranton, things are getting exciting because everyone is showing up to Diwali. They're arriving, they're walking in. It's really, really bright and colorful and there's music playing.
他有别的计划。他准备好派对了。当艾德·赫尔姆斯（Ed Helms）举起那个野格酒瓶和酒杯时，他的表情太搞笑了。你看到了安迪在大学时是什么样子的，你会想，“哦，伙计。”嗯，回到斯克兰顿，事情变得令人兴奋，因为每个人都出现在排灯节上。他们到达了，走进来。它真的非常明亮、色彩斑斓，还有音乐在播放。
And Phyllis is like, isn't it fun to take our shoes off? And Angela's like, I wish not everyone took their shoes off. And Kevin's like, stop it. I told you it was a condition. So you guys remember in Grief Counseling, we talked about a deleted scene that would have been in the episode where Angela and Kevin go off again about his sweaty feet.
菲利斯说，“脱掉鞋子不是很有趣吗？”安吉拉说，“我希望不是每个人都脱掉鞋子。”凯文说，“别说了。我告诉过你这是条件。”所以你们还记得在《悲伤辅导》（Grief Counseling）中，我们谈到了一个删减片段，本应出现在那一集中，安吉拉和凯文再次谈论他出汗的脚。
Yes, this is a call back to a deleted scene. So it's going to go unappreciated by most viewers, but those diehard viewers who watch those deleted scenes will know what this means. I feel like someone in the writers' room was really determined to make sure we had scenes about Kevin's feet. I feel like it was a note card on the wall
是的，这是对删减片段的回应。所以大多数观众会忽略它，但那些观看删减片段的铁杆观众会知道这意味着什么。我觉得编剧室里的某个人真的下定决心要确保我们有关于凯文脚的场景。我觉得墙上有一张便条纸
that said Kevin's sweaty feet. And someone loved it and kept note card on the on the wall that said Kevin's sweaty feet and someone loved it and kept wanting to get it in the episodes. Well this is Angela's worst nightmare. People taking off all their shoes even minus Kevin's sweaty feet. I mean this is just not how she wants to be at a party. No, no. So Angela we got a fan question about these Diwali scenes. It comes from Sarahbeth Miller. She asked, was this a real Diwali celebration happening in the filming of this episode?
上面写着“凯文出汗的脚”。有人喜欢它，并把它保留在墙上，上面写着“凯文出汗的脚”，有人喜欢它，并一直想把它放进剧集里。嗯，这是安吉拉的噩梦。人们脱掉所有的鞋子，甚至不考虑凯文出汗的脚。我是说，这根本不是她想在派对上表现的样子。不，不。所以安吉拉，我们收到了一个关于这些排灯节场景的粉丝问题。它来自莎拉贝丝·米勒（Sarahbeth Miller）。她问，“拍摄这一集时，这真的是一个真实的排灯节庆祝活动吗？”
How did you get all of those people in those beautiful costumes? Great question, Sarahbeth. I mean, there are so many people in this scene. So here's the thing. It was not a real Diwali festival. That was all put together by our amazing crew, just specifically for this episode.
你是怎么让所有那些人穿上那些漂亮服装的？好问题，莎拉贝丝。我是说，这个场景里有很多人。所以事情是这样的。这不是一个真实的排灯节。那是我们出色的剧组专门为这一集拼凑起来的。
Yes, our set designer, Michael Gallenberg and his team, they decorated that whole gym. Michael had to do a lot of research in order to transform the gymnasium to feel like a real Diwali festival. So I think he would be very proud to know that you wondered if this was real. Like maybe we just stepped into an existing festival. No, they made the whole thing. They did a fantastic job. As far as costumes go, my character did not get to dress up, Jenna. I was so bummed. Yeah. You know, I mean, she actually is just wearing
是的，我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）和他的团队，他们装饰了整个体育馆。迈克尔不得不做大量的研究，以便把体育馆改造成感觉像一个真实的排灯节。所以我认为他会很自豪地知道你怀疑这是不是真的。就像也许我们只是走进了一个现有的节日。不，他们制作了整个场景。他们做得太棒了。至于服装，我的角色没能打扮，珍娜。我太沮丧了。是的。你知道，我是说，她其实只是穿着
what she wore to work. She didn't even change out of her work clothes. I know. But some of the cast did get to dress up. BJ, Rain, Mindy, and I'm sure our wardrobe stylist was thrilled to do something other than just drab office attire. They used to get so excited every time we got to wear anything other than our office attire. And Pam didn't really dress up, but she is not in her office attire, which was fun.
她上班穿的衣服。她甚至没换掉工作服。我知道。但有些演员确实打扮了。BJ、雷恩（Rain）、敏迪，我相信我们的服装造型师很高兴能做一些除了枯燥的办公室服装以外的事情。每当我们能穿除了办公室服装以外的任何东西时，他们都会非常兴奋。帕姆并没有真正打扮，但她没有穿她的办公室服装，这很有趣。
I had a whole separate fitting for that. We got to see Casual Pam. And did you notice I got to wear my hair differently as well? But we did find out some interesting trivia about all the other background actors who were dressed up for this festival. Yes, we went to Kentipedia, and he said our casting office worked with Central Casting.
我为此专门进行了一次单独的试装。我们得以见到了“休闲版帕姆”。你注意到我的发型也换了吗？但我们确实发现了一些关于其他为这个节日盛装打扮的背景演员的有趣琐事。是的，我们查阅了“肯特百科”，他说我们的选角办公室与中央选角公司（Central Casting）进行了合作。
Now Central Casting is a casting agency in Los Angeles. They specialize in sort of the background actors and filling out the picture, right? Yeah. Central Casting reached out to a lot of the Indian community here in Los Angeles to hire those background players. All in all, Kent said we had 100 extras working this episode, and every single one of them
中央选角公司是洛杉矶的一家选角机构。他们专门负责背景演员和填充画面，对吧？是的。中央选角公司联系了洛杉矶的许多印度社区，雇佣了那些背景演员。总而言之，肯特说我们这一集有100名临时演员，他们每个人
brought their own very beautiful costuming for us to use. And to kind of fill out the world, Kent also hired a professional dance company to come and lead us in some of the dances. He found a company called NDM Dance Productions, and he hired their director choreographer Dev Mahajan. And Dev hired eight dancers. He choreographed, rehearsed their dance
都带来了自己非常漂亮的服装供我们使用。为了充实场景，肯特还雇佣了一家专业的舞蹈公司来带领我们跳一些舞蹈。他找到了一家名为NDM Dance Productions的公司，并雇佣了他们的导演兼编舞德夫·马哈詹（Dev Mahajan）。德夫雇了八名舞者。他编排并排练了他们的舞蹈，
in the morning of that day four of shooting is when we shot all the dancing. And then we filmed it later in the afternoon and all the dancers wear their own costumes as well. I actually went to the website. Of course you did, lady. You went to the dancers website. What'd you find out?
在拍摄的第四天早上，我们拍摄了所有的舞蹈镜头。然后我们在下午晚些时候进行了拍摄，所有的舞者也都穿着他们自己的服装。我真的去看了他们的网站。你当然去了，女士。你去了舞者的网站。你发现了什么？
They have appeared on tons of shows. So You Think You Can Dance, E! Live Oscar coverage, Good Morning America, Superstars of Dance, and MTV's America's Best Dance Crew. If you want to look them up, you can find them at ndmdance.com. It was super cool and it really did end up feeling like a real party, like a real celebration. It really did. I wish my character wanted to participate more because me, Angela, that is me, would have been right out there, like, just having a great time. So it was always hard in these moments to not get to be in costume and not participate and be kind of the grump on the wall, you know?
他们出现在无数节目中。比如《舞林争霸》、《E!频道奥斯卡直播报道》、《早安美国》、《舞蹈巨星》和MTV的《全美最佳舞团》。如果你想了解他们，可以在ndmdance.com找到他们。这太酷了，最后真的感觉像是一场真正的派对，一场真正的庆祝活动。确实如此。我真希望我的角色能多参与一些，因为我，安吉拉，也就是我，肯定会冲上去，玩得很开心。所以，在这些时刻不能穿上戏服参与其中，只能像个扫兴鬼一样站在墙边，总是很难受，你知道吗？
I do. And we'll talk a little bit about my dancing later, but I did get to dance a little bit, and I was thrilled. Yes. Very fun. All right, so yeah, so there are people that got to dress up, people that didn't. Michael and Carol walk in with a whole different idea
我懂。我们稍后再谈谈我的舞姿，但我确实跳了一点，我当时很兴奋。是的。非常有趣。好吧，所以有些人可以盛装打扮，有些人则不行。迈克尔和卡罗尔带着完全不同的想法走了进来，
of what this party is. Michael has clearly told Carol that this is a costume party, so she arrives dressed as a cheerleader. With pom-poms. With pom-poms. And Michael has his old Halloween costume on. He has his paper mache head. We had a fan question from Melinda O'Brien.
以为这是什么派对。迈克尔显然告诉卡罗尔这是一个化装舞会，所以她打扮成啦啦队长来了。带着啦啦队彩球。带着彩球。而迈克尔穿着他旧的万圣节服装。他戴着那个纸糊的头套。我们收到了梅琳达·奥布莱恩的一个粉丝提问。
Was Michael's costume the same one from the Halloween episode or did they have to make another one? Oh no, Melinda, we save everything. Everything that anyone wore or held or used or interacted with on the office goes into a giant warehouse. It's tagged. It's almost like an evidence room. So when they wrote that into this episode, they just went to that warehouse and they picked up that paper mache head and put it right on his shoulder again. That's right. It's like the end of Raiders of the Lost Ark. It's like rows and rows of boxes with
迈克尔的服装是万圣节那一集里的同一套吗？还是他们不得不又做了一套？哦不，梅琳达，我们什么都留着。任何人在《办公室》里穿过、拿过、用过或接触过的东西都会被存进一个巨大的仓库。它们都有标签。简直就像个证物室。所以当他们把这个情节写进这一集时，他们只是去了那个仓库，拿起了那个纸糊头套，又把它戴回了他的肩膀上。没错。就像《夺宝奇兵》的结尾。就像一排排的箱子，上面有
dates, tags, episode names. So they went right to that box. And of course, Michael, you know, he can take the head off and then he just looks like he's in a suit. But Carol is stuck now as a cheerleader because Michael thought this was Indian Halloween. because Michael thought this was Indian Halloween. Yes, I know. Poor Carol. She is such a sport in this episode. She has to endure so much. And Nancy Carell just knocked it out of the park. She plays it so perfect of just sort of, like,
日期、标签、剧集名称。所以他们直接去了那个箱子。当然，迈克尔，你知道，他可以把头套摘下来，然后看起来就像穿着西装一样。但卡罗尔现在被困在啦啦队长的装扮里了，因为迈克尔以为这是印度万圣节。因为迈克尔以为这是印度万圣节。是的，我知道。可怜的卡罗尔。她在这一集里真是太配合了。她不得不忍受这么多。而南希·卡瑞尔表现得太棒了。她演得非常完美，那种
quietly enduring this awkward evening. While dressed like a cheerleader. Yeah. Well, let's move over to the buffet. Angela's at the buffet. She asks if they have any vegetarian options. She doesn't even seem satisfied when she learns that everything is vegetarian. It's all vegetarian.
默默忍受这个尴尬夜晚的感觉。还穿着啦啦队服。是的。好吧，让我们转到自助餐区。安吉拉在自助餐区。她问他们有没有素食选择。当她得知所有东西都是素食时，她似乎并不满意。全是素食。
She's just in full grump mode. She's like, just give me some bread. And then the guy hands her the bread with his hands. And Angela, you have a line here that I am fairly certain you improvised. Oh, yeah, I say you used your hands as I walk away. And I did improvise that because the guy literally did hand it to me with his hands. And I thought that's not good. You shouldn't use some tongs. Some tongs. He just handed it to me with his hands. And so I improvised that's not good. You shouldn't use some tongs. Some tongs, he just handed to me with his hands.
她完全处于抱怨模式。她说，给我点面包就行。然后那个人用手把面包递给了她。安吉拉，你在这里有一句台词，我相当确定是你即兴发挥的。哦，是的，我走开时说“你用手拿”。我确实是即兴发挥的，因为那个人真的是用手递给我的。我想那不好。你不应该用夹子吗？用夹子。他只是用手递给了我。所以我即兴说了“那不好，你不应该用夹子吗？用夹子，他只是用手递给了我”。
And so I improvised that line and it stayed in and it makes me laugh. Of course she goes ahead and eats it. So I guess she's not too concerned, but it's clearly she's just like not having a good time. And she's a little like grossed out because she's seeing a lot of feet. And now a guy just handed her bread with his hands, a stranger.
所以我即兴说了那句台词，它被保留了下来，这让我发笑。当然，她还是把它吃了。所以我猜她并不太在意，但很明显她玩得不开心。而且她有点恶心，因为她看到了很多脚。现在又有一个陌生人用手递给她面包。
Well, in the script, it says that you take a bite and say, ugh, garlic. We had some fan questions about the foods. Stacey and Rutby both wrote in to say, was any of that delicious looking buffet food real? Did you get to sample some of the cuisine while filming this episode? Guys, it was all real food.
嗯，剧本里写的是你咬了一口然后说，呃，大蒜。我们收到了一些关于食物的粉丝提问。斯泰西和鲁特比都写信问，那些看起来很美味的自助餐食物是真的吗？拍摄这一集时你尝过那些菜肴吗？伙计们，那全是真食物。
It was all real. It was all delicious. Kent told me we hired a specialty food stylist to create the food, that it was authentically prepared, and we had it all three days of filming, and we got to eat it, and I remember that. It was delicious. It was delicious. I only got to eat the naan, but it was very good naan.
全是真实的。而且都很好吃。肯特告诉我，我们雇了一位专业的美食造型师来制作这些食物，它们是地道烹饪的，我们在拍摄的三天里都有这些食物，我们还吃了，我记得。很好吃。很好吃。我只吃了馕，但那是很好的馕。
Oh, I ate between takes. I just ate it. You don't even see Pam eating it on screen. I was like, I will eat this. Well, now we come to one of the moments in this episode that is one of my favorites, Angela. This is when Ryan meets Kelly's giggly sisters. Yeah. It's so, so cute. We got some fan questions from Lindsay, Bridget, and Dan, who all want to know, do you know what Kelly's sister is saying when they're talking to Ryan? They're saying something about Zach Braff. OK, here's what the three little girls say. They say, Kelly likes Zach Braff.
哦，我在拍摄间隙吃了。我直接就吃了。你在屏幕上甚至看不到帕姆在吃。我当时想，我要吃这个。好吧，现在我们来到了这一集中我最喜欢的时刻之一，安吉拉。这是瑞安见到凯莉那些爱笑的姐妹们的时候。是的。太可爱了。我们收到了来自琳赛、布里奇特和丹的粉丝提问，他们都想知道，凯莉的姐妹们在和瑞安说话时到底在说什么？她们在说关于扎克·布拉夫的事情。好的，这三个小女孩说的是：凯莉喜欢扎克·布拉夫。
That's what they're saying in Hindi. And they're sort of like teasing him. They were so cute. And they were played by Tanvir Atwal, Ananya Keper, and Jaisha Patel. Well, the little girl who plays Kelly's sister that says the Zach Braff line, that's Jaisha. I found her on Instagram.
这就是她们用印地语说的。她们是在逗他。她们太可爱了。她们由坦维尔·阿特瓦尔、阿南亚·凯珀和贾莎·帕特尔饰演。嗯，那个说扎克·布拉夫台词的凯莉的妹妹，是贾莎。我在Instagram上找到了她。
And I reached out to her to ask her about what it was like to be on the show and she wrote back. I can't wait to share. She must be like a grown lady now. She is a grown woman now. She told me she was 13 years old when she shot this episode. She said she had not really heard about the show.
我联系了她，问她参加这个节目的感受，她回信了。我迫不及待想分享。她现在一定是个成年女士了。她现在确实是一位成年女性了。她告诉我，拍摄这一集时她才13岁。她说她当时并没有真正听说过这个节目。
She was still watching Disney Channel, she said. But she said her dad took her to the audition and she remembers walking into the casting office and just seeing tons of other kids who were all there for the same role. And she said the audition was just her saying that one line in Hindi. And she said she didn't speak any Hindi. So her dad told her how to say it about five seconds
她说她当时还在看迪士尼频道。但她说她爸爸带她去试镜，她记得走进选角办公室，看到成堆的其他孩子都在为同一个角色而来。她说试镜就是让她用印地语说那一句台词。她说她根本不会说印地语。所以她爸爸告诉她怎么说，就在她走进试镜房间前
before she went into the audition room. So her dad told her how to say it about five seconds before she went into the audition room. And then she got the part. So she said she was so excited. And I asked her what it was like to be on set if she had any memories. And she sent back the sweetest message. So we're going to play it for you now.
大约五秒钟。所以她爸爸告诉她怎么说，就在她走进试镜房间前大约五秒钟。然后她就得到了这个角色。所以她说她非常兴奋。我问她片场是什么样的，她有什么记忆。她发回了一条最甜蜜的信息。所以我们现在要为你播放它。
I remember Rainn Wilson walking up to me and shoving a lightsaber in my hand and yelling, lightsaber war. I also remember getting to know Mindy Kaling and BJ Novak who were so sweet to me. Meeting Mindy Kaling really meant a lot to me growing up because I didn't really see many Indian actresses in the entertainment industry at that time and I love what Mindy has done with her platform and she is still a huge inspiration for me till this day. I also remember all of the delicious Indian food on set and getting to dance all day and I remember being so happy that I had the chance to wear my Indian clothes. Isn't that so sweet?
我记得雷恩·威尔森走到我面前，把一把光剑塞进我手里，大喊“光剑大战”。我还记得认识了明迪·卡灵和BJ·诺瓦克，他们对我非常亲切。见到明迪·卡灵对我成长过程中意义重大，因为当时我在娱乐业并没有看到很多印度女演员，我喜欢明迪利用她的平台所做的一切，直到今天她仍然是我巨大的灵感来源。我还记得片场所有美味的印度食物，还有整天跳舞，我记得能有机会穿上我的印度服装我感到非常高兴。这不是很甜吗？
That is wonderful. As I listened to it, I was just smiling so big because that is everything about that message is lovely. I love all of her memories. She's absolutely right about Mindy and what Mindy has done. And she's such an inspiration to so many people. Yes. Yeah.
那太棒了。当我听的时候，我笑得合不拢嘴，因为那条信息里的每一件事都很可爱。我喜欢她所有的记忆。关于明迪和明迪所做的一切，她是绝对正确的。她是许多人的灵感来源。是的。是的。
She told me after the episode aired, she had classmates and family members reaching out that they had recorded it and taking pictures of her name in the credits. So that was when she was 13. She really wanted to be an actress. She said when she was 15, she decided she wanted to go into journalism. And now Jayshah is the morning news reporter at NBC 15 in Mobile, Alabama. She told me she has to go to bed at four o'clock in the afternoon because she has to be in the studio at 330 in the morning.
她告诉我，剧集播出后，她的同学和家人联系她，说他们录下来了，还拍下了她在演职员表里的名字。所以那是她13岁的时候。她真的很想成为一名演员。她说她15岁时决定从事新闻业。现在贾莎是阿拉巴马州莫比尔市NBC 15频道的早间新闻记者。她告诉我，她必须在下午四点睡觉，因为她凌晨3点30分就得在演播室。
I have always heard that about these morning anchors on the East Coast, that they have to get up so early. That's amazing though, Jayshia, that is so cool. Isn't that so cool? She said all her coworkers know about her appearance on the office and that fans will mention to her because she's Indian, they'll mention the Diwali episode and then she always like blows their mind
我一直听说东海岸的这些早间主播必须起得那么早。不过这太神奇了，贾莎，太酷了。这不是很酷吗？她说她所有的同事都知道她出演过《办公室》，粉丝们因为她是印度人，会向她提到排灯节那一集，然后当她说“哦不，我参演了”时，总是让他们大吃一惊。
when she says, oh no, I was in it. So I thought that was so sweet. I was in it. I say a line that offends Ryan the temp. Yes, exactly. Except he doesn't quite know he's being the butt of a joke. But she said being on the office was one of her most memorable moments of her childhood.
所以我认为这太甜了。我参演了。我说了一句冒犯临时工瑞安的台词。是的，没错。除了他还没完全意识到自己成了笑柄。但她说参演《办公室》是她童年最难忘的时刻之一。
I also love that, you know, I'm sure Rain improvised going up to her with that lightsaber. There's a bunch of deleted scenes where he's fighting with kids with lightsabers. And it didn't make it in. But he, he, Rain looked very much in his element, like that's how he bonds with children. Yes. Angela, should we check in on those folks at Stanford, see how they're doing? You mean the folks drinking Jaegermeister?
我也喜欢这一点，你知道，我敢肯定雷恩是即兴拿着光剑走向她的。有很多删减片段是他和孩子们用光剑打斗的。但没放进去。但他，雷恩看起来非常自在，就像那是他与孩子建立联系的方式。是的。安吉拉，我们应该去看看斯坦福的那些人，看看他们怎么样了？你是说那些喝野格利口酒的人吗？
Yeah. How are they? And Angela, did you see what they ordered for dinner? Oh, Jenna, you and I know firsthand. You do not drink a lot of alcohol and only eat sushi. Now, Angela, why do we know that firsthand? We know that because at the Golden Globes, was it the Golden Globes, Jenna? Oh, lady, I was thinking of my bachelorette party that you planned for me.
是的。他们怎么样了？安吉拉，你看到他们晚餐点了什么吗？哦，珍娜，你和我亲身经历过。你不喝太多酒，只吃寿司。那么，安吉拉，为什么我们亲身经历过？我们知道是因为在金球奖上，那是金球奖吗，珍娜？哦，女士，我在想你为我策划的单身派对。
Oh, well, there was the Golden Globes, but the bachelorette? Wait, have we repeated this mistake multiple times? Yes, except the second time I did better. The first time it did not work out well for me. The second time, if memory serves, sorry to say this on here, but it hit your sister pretty hard. Yeah. Guys, Angela planned a bachelorette party for me
哦，好吧，有金球奖，但单身派对呢？等等，我们是不是多次重复了这个错误？是的，除了第二次我做得更好。第一次对我来说不太顺利。第二次，如果记忆没出错的话，抱歉在这里说出来，但它让你姐姐很难受。是的。伙计们，安吉拉为我策划了一个单身派对，
when I was getting married to Lee, and she took us all out for a sushi dinner. It was a fancy schmancy sushi place in Beverly Hills that I'd never eaten at. I'd only dreamed of. And I was like, can we go there for my bachelorette? They were thrilled to have us. It was so cute. All of the ladies from the office were there.
当我准备嫁给李的时候，她带我们所有人去吃寿司晚餐。那是比佛利山庄一家花哨的寿司店，我从来没吃过。我只梦到过。我说，我们能去那里办我的单身派对吗？他们很高兴能接待我们。太可爱了。办公室里的女士们都在那里。
All of my other friends were there. And afterwards you took us to a dance club. Hold up lady. We're gonna get this right. First of all, the sushi place was your idea. And then after the sushi place, you guys, I got cupcakes with like her face on it. It was so cute.
我所有的其他朋友也都在那里。之后你带我们去了一家舞厅。等等，女士。我们要把这件事搞清楚。首先，寿司店是你的主意。然后在那之后，伙计们，我买了上面印着她脸的纸杯蛋糕。太可爱了。
We had lots of free drinks sent over. The restaurant was very kind and lots of great sushi. And then after the dinner, I was like, well, thank you guys. And Jenna was like, what's next? And I was like, well, thank you guys. And Jenna was like, what's next? And I was like, uh, what? Wait, what? Do you not? Is this true?
我们收到了很多免费赠送的饮料。餐厅非常友善，寿司也很棒。晚餐后，我说，好吧，谢谢大家。珍娜说，接下来去哪？我说，好吧，谢谢大家。珍娜说，接下来去哪？我说，呃，什么？等等，什么？你不记得了吗？这是真的吗？
I do not remember this. Do you not know this? No. Lady, all I had planned was the dinner. I didn't plan anything after. Is this the first time you're ever hearing of this? Yes. This is putting the dance club into perspective now, because I thought at the time it was
我不记得了。你不知道吗？不。女士，我只计划了晚餐。我没计划之后的事。这是你第一次听说吗？是的。这让舞厅的事有了新的视角，因为我当时觉得
an odd choice, because we've never in a million years gone clubbing, and now we were suddenly clubbing for my bachelorette, but I was like, this is great. What a fun idea. Yeah, I should say, you guys, we had a car. I got one of the big limos, you know, that we could all pile in. And I called a friend of mine who was like, always kind of like, you know, you have that one friend that's like, I got a hookup, I got a hookup.
这是一个奇怪的选择，因为我们从来没去过夜店，而现在我们突然为了我的单身派对去夜店了，但我当时想，这太棒了。多有趣的主意。是的，我应该说，伙计们，我们有一辆车。我租了一辆大豪华轿车，你知道，我们可以挤进去。我给我的一个朋友打了电话，她总是那种，你知道，你总有那种朋友说，“我有门路，我有门路”。
Yeah, I'm in the know. I called my friend Tess and I was like, Tess, Jenna wants to go dancing. I were in Beverly Hills, what do I do? What do I do? And she was like, I'm on it. Give me like five, 10 minutes. I said, okay. So we kind? What do I do? And she was like, I'm on it. Give me like 5, 10 minutes. I said, OK.
是的，我门儿清。我给我的朋友苔丝打了电话，我说，苔丝，珍娜想去跳舞。我们在比佛利山庄，我该怎么办？我该怎么办？她说，交给我。给我五到十分钟。我说，好的。所以我们有点？我该怎么办？她说，交给我。给我五到十分钟。我说，好的。
So we kind of hung out a little bit. And I was like, I'm sorting out some stuff, guys. I do remember hanging out on the sidewalk outside the. Yes, it's because I didn't have a plan. Because the restaurant. All I had planned for was fancy sushi. And our evening would have been over at like 10 o'clock. Yeah.
所以我们就在那儿闲逛了一会儿。我说，我在处理一些事情，伙计们。我确实记得在外面的人行道上闲逛。是的，因为我没有计划。因为餐厅。我只计划了高档寿司。我们的夜晚本该在10点左右结束的。是的。
Anyway, I get a call from Tess and she goes, all right, Angela's pretty last minute. It's like, you know, a Thursday night in Beverly Hills. So I did get you in this one club. I know this guy, he's got a booth for you and they're gonna give you drink service. It's kind of a random club, but it'll be fun. You guys can dance.
总之，我接到苔丝的电话，她说，好吧，安吉拉真是临时抱佛脚。你知道，这是比佛利山庄的周四晚上。所以我确实让你进了这家俱乐部。我认识这家伙，他有个包厢给你，他们会提供酒水服务。这是一家有点随意的俱乐部，但会很有趣。你们可以跳舞。
Angela, it's the only time I've ever experienced bottle service. Bottle service is where you like, they bring you just bottles of alcohol and then mixers and like little cut limes to your table, and you make your drinks. Also, when they walk it over, everyone starts doing, at least for us, I think this was the norm, because I would see different people get bottle service, and it was like, B-B-B-B fatty in the air. It was so weird. It was so bizarre. They had. It was crazy dancing. I remember we got in trouble because we were dancing on top of the couches and we got reprimanded for that. But guys, on our stomachs of sushi, mixed with bottle service,
安吉拉，这是我唯一一次体验瓶装酒服务。瓶装酒服务就是他们给你拿来整瓶的酒，还有调酒饮料和切好的小青柠，放在你的桌子上，你自己调酒。而且，当他们走过来时，每个人都开始，至少对我们来说，我认为这是常态，因为我会看到不同的人享受瓶装酒服务，就像是，B-B-B-B，空气中弥漫着脂肪。太奇怪了。太离谱了。他们有。那真是疯狂的舞蹈。我记得我们惹麻烦了，因为我们在沙发上跳舞，还因此受到了训斥。但是伙计们，在我们的寿司胃里，混合着瓶装酒服务，
long story short, at the end of the night, as the limo is dropping everyone off, my sister puked in Ellie Kemper's bushes. I puked when I got home, it was in my hair, I slept in it. It was an epic night, but that's what you get when you mix sushi and a lot of booze. And that is what is in store for these guys in Stanford. Yeah, as Jen and I rewatch this episode, I texted her and I was like, Oh, lady, alcohol and sushi. It's so true. It is so true. Should we go back to Diwali because Roy has arrived and he is watching Pam dance and have fun?
长话短说，那天晚上结束时，当豪华轿车送每个人回家时，我姐姐吐在了艾丽·坎伯的灌木丛里。我回家时吐了，吐在头发里，我就那样睡着了。那是一个史诗般的夜晚，但这就是当你混合寿司和大量烈酒时会发生的事情。这就是斯坦福那些人即将面临的。是的，当珍娜和我重看这一集时，我给她发短信说，哦，女士，酒精和寿司。太真实了。太真实了。我们应该回到排灯节吗，因为罗伊到了，他正在看帕姆跳舞玩乐？
And I have a full Mindy catch for you right here. And we've got a sting for it and everything. -♪ FULL MINDY! -♪ There you go. It's a full Mindy catch. Mira Durring wrote in to say, at the Diwali party when Roy walks in, Beyoncé's crazy in love say, at the Diwali party when Roy walks in, Beyonce's crazy in love is playing in the background.
我这里有一个完整的“明迪捕捉”给你。我们甚至为此准备了一个音效。-♪ 完整的明迪！ -♪ 给你。这是一个完整的明迪捕捉。米拉·杜林写信说，在排灯节派对上，当罗伊走进来时，碧昂丝的《Crazy in Love》在背景中播放。
And Angela, this was a note in the script. Mindy wrote in what song would be playing when Roy walks in and that it would be a Beyonce song. So I think this is a full, full Mindy. I love it. It's a very subtle full Mindy. I love it. It's a very subtle, full Mindy. It's like full Mindy when you don't even see Mindy, but her presence is still there. Exactly. And, you know, my dance partner, we talked about this in the interview with Mindy, my
安吉拉，这是剧本里的一个备注。明迪写下了罗伊走进来时应该播放什么歌，而且那应该是一首碧昂丝的歌。所以我认为这是一个完整的、完整的明迪。我喜欢它。这是一个非常微妙的、完整的明迪。就像当你看不到明迪，但她的存在感依然在那里时，就是完整的明迪。没错。而且，你知道，我的舞伴，我们在明迪的采访中谈到了这一点，我的
dance partner, Vally, okay, he was well known by the writers because he was a writer on My Name is Earl at the time. And he went on to write on 30 Rock and was one of the executive producers of Modern Family. Oh my gosh. I know. Well, Mindy did say, guys, he wasn't an actor. He was like a friend of ours.
舞伴瓦利，好吧，他被编剧们所熟知，因为他当时是《愚人善事》的编剧。他后来去写了《我为喜剧狂》，还是《摩登家庭》的执行制片人之一。天哪。我知道。好吧，明迪确实说过，伙计们，他不是演员。他就像我们的朋友。
That's so wild. Well, can I ask you a little bit about your dance moves there, Ms. Fisher? You can. What are you gonna say? I've danced with you. And I can tell you right now, folks, that was not a choreographed dance routine.
太疯狂了。好吧，我可以问问你那里的舞步吗，费舍女士？你可以。你想说什么？我和你跳过舞。我可以现在就告诉你，伙计们，那不是编排好的舞蹈动作。
That was just Jenna being Jenna. Yeah. We had a fan question from Zaria Collins, who asked that same question. Were those dance moves choreographed? Oh, no. Oh, no. That's all Miss Fisher.
那只是珍娜做回了珍娜。是的。我们收到了扎里亚·柯林斯的一个粉丝提问，她问了同样的问题。那些舞步是编排好的吗？哦，不。哦，不。那全是费舍小姐。
That's me fully dancing with my heart and soul. That's hello St. Louis. St. Louis prom. That sounds of Scranton right there. That's the same girl who made a sounds of Scranton playlist everyone. There I am. You could almost rewind me and put me in my high school gym right there. Well, something is going to happen that is super awkward because that is Michael's way. Michael's way is to take a wonderful moment and make everyone cringe. And the Diwali was going to be no exception.
那是我全心全意地在跳舞。那是你好圣路易斯。圣路易斯舞会。那听起来就是斯克兰顿的声音。那是那个制作了“斯克兰顿之声”播放列表的女孩，大家。我就是我。你几乎可以倒带，把我放回我高中的体育馆里。好吧，有些事情要发生了，超级尴尬，因为那是迈克尔的方式。迈克尔的方式就是把一个美好的时刻变成让每个人都感到尴尬。排灯节也不例外。
He has this amazing scene with Mindy's parents that play Kelly's parents, which we already talked about. And he's so inspired by their love. He's gonna do it. Yeah. He's gonna do it. Their commitment. Yeah. He's gonna propose to Carol in front of a whole room of strangers on their ninth date. Yes. She's like, Carol, will you do me the honor of making me your husband? Of making me your husband. And she's like, can we talk about this in private?
他和明迪的父母有一场精彩的戏，他们饰演凯莉的父母，我们已经谈过了。他被他们的爱所激励。他要做了。是的。他要做了。他们的承诺。是的。他要在第九次约会时，在满屋子陌生人面前向卡罗尔求婚。是的。她说，卡罗尔，你愿意给我这个荣幸让我成为你的丈夫吗？让我成为你的丈夫。她说，我们能私下谈谈吗？
And this is one of my favorite moments in movies and TV where he's like, what? Into a microphone, she's like, can we talk about it in private? And then he's like, Oh, man, oh crap. Well, they have the scene out in the parking lot, Jenna, and it made me laugh so hard that, you know, Carol is like, I can't do this, Michael, I can't do it. And his last ditch effort, his last few moments, what is he going to say that might change her mind? He's going to go for it. What could he say to change this woman's mind? Do you know what he says? Let me come with you. I have this book, the Kama Sutra. She says, she's like, good night,
这是我在电影和电视中最喜欢的时刻之一，他当时说，什么？对着麦克风，她说，我们能私下谈谈吗？然后他说，哦，天哪，哦糟糕。好吧，他们在停车场有那场戏，珍娜，这让我笑得太厉害了，你知道，卡罗尔说，我不能这样做，迈克尔，我不能。他最后的努力，他最后的时刻，他会说什么来改变她的主意？他要豁出去了。他能说什么来改变这个女人的主意？你知道他说了什么吗？让我跟你一起去。我有这本书，《爱经》。她说，她说，晚安，
Michael. Well, at this point, Pam is, she's talking to Valley and she's realizing something. She wants to reach out to Jim. So she's gonna text Jim. Well, that thing happened. That thing happened, which is, you know, this crazy moment just happened and who does she wanna share it with, right?
迈克尔。好吧，此时，帕姆正在和瓦利说话，她意识到了一些事情。她想联系吉姆。所以她要给吉姆发短信。好吧，那件事发生了。那件事发生了，你知道，这个疯狂的时刻刚刚发生，她想和谁分享呢，对吧？
This is how you know you really care about someone. Your person out there, folks, is the person you want to tell everything to right after it happens. It's who you bounce everything off of. And Pam wants to tell her person what just happened. But she runs into Angela. She needs to get her shoes. And there is Angela guarding the shoes, she says. And eating her dry naan. By the way, Angela, fan question from Rainy Gregg,
这就是你怎么知道你真的很在乎某人。伙计们，你的那个人，就是你在事情发生后想告诉一切的人。是你向其倾诉一切的人。帕姆想告诉她的人刚刚发生了什么。但她遇到了安吉拉。她需要拿她的鞋子。安吉拉守着鞋子，她说。还在吃她干巴巴的馕。顺便说一句，安吉拉，雷尼·格雷格的粉丝提问，
was the naan dry? No. Was it actually dry? No, it wasn't. It was perfectly fine. I would say that too. I ate some of that naan. It was wonderful.
馕是干的吗？不。它真的干吗？不，不是。它非常好。我也会那么说。我吃了那个馕。太棒了。
I was glad to have it. I was probably hungry. Well, Jen and I used to always get so tickled to have scenes together, because it rarely happened. So we were really excited about this. I loved shooting the scene with you, and I love it so much, I just want us to play it. Sam, can you play it?
我很高兴能吃到它。我可能饿了。好吧，珍娜和我过去总是很高兴能一起演戏，因为这种情况很少发生。所以我们对此非常兴奋。我喜欢和你拍那场戏，我太喜欢它了，我只想让我们播放它。萨姆，你能播放吗？
It's hot in there. How's the naan? Dry. Look like you were having fun. I am. You should come dance with us. I have to watch our shoes so they don't get stolen. Who are you texting? No one. Aww. But also lady, my character is so nosy. So nosy? Who are you texting? Yeah, look like you were having fun. Who are you texting? I mean, who am I to ask you who you're texting? You're the party police. Also, you're single.
里面很热。馕怎么样？干。看起来你玩得很开心。我是。你应该来和我们一起跳舞。我得看着我们的鞋子，以免被偷。你在给谁发短信？没谁。噢。但女士，我的角色太爱管闲事了。太爱管闲事？你在给谁发短信？是的，看起来你玩得很开心。你在给谁发短信？我是说，我有什么资格问你在给谁发短信？你是派对警察。而且，你是单身。
Dwight made this big announcement that he's single. I don't know. Maybe you're texting Dwight. What's happening? Angela's spinning out in this episode. And a lot of those scenes ended up getting deleted, but it would be a fun watch to go back and watch them because that is why you are so intense in this episode. Yeah.
德怀特宣布他单身了。我不知道。也许你在给德怀特发短信。发生了什么？安吉拉在这一集里有点失控。很多场景最终被删减了，但回去看它们会很有趣，因为这就是为什么你在这一集里表现得如此强烈。是的。
So now Pam is going to make it outside. She hasn't received a text back from Jim, and she sits with Michael. Michael tries to relate to her. He's like, wow, they're both victims of broken engagements. And Pam's like, well, I mean, except that you were never actually engaged, but whatever. She tries to bond with Michael, and of course, he does that thing that you were just talking about,
所以现在帕姆要出去了。她没有收到吉姆的回复，她和迈克尔坐在一起。迈克尔试图与她产生共鸣。他说，哇，他们都是订婚破裂的受害者。帕姆说，好吧，我是说，除了你从来没有真正订婚过，但随便吧。她试图与迈克尔建立联系，当然，他做了你刚才说的那件事，
where he just takes it one step too far, and he starts to lean in like he's going to kiss her. So awkward. We got a lot of mail about it, Angela. Ruby, Alexandra, and Vanessa Ortiz all wrote in to ask if that was a scripted moment when Michael tries to kiss Pam. What was it like? It was scripted, you guys. That was in the script. And then the thing, that great line that Pam has where she says, I'm rejecting your kiss. He's like, she's like, what are you doing?
他做得太过分了，他开始倾身，好像要吻她。太尴尬了。我们收到了很多关于此的邮件，安吉拉。鲁比、亚历山德拉和凡妮莎·奥尔蒂斯都写信问，迈克尔试图吻帕姆时，那是剧本里的时刻吗？那是什么感觉？那是剧本里的，伙计们。那在剧本里。然后那件事，帕姆说的那句精彩台词，她说，我拒绝你的吻。他说，她说，你在做什么？
He's like, what are you doing? She's like, I'm rejecting your kiss. That's what I'm doing. Yeah. What are you doing? That was all scripted. And Angela, I was so excited to do that scene because I remember staying late that evening
他说，你在做什么？她说，我拒绝你的吻。这就是我在做的。是的。你在做什么？那全是剧本里的。安吉拉，我非常兴奋能拍那场戏，因为我记得那天晚上留得很晚
and shooting outside. I talked about this before when I had that scene with John up on the roof where Pam and Jim eat the grilled cheese sandwiches. It was one of those warm summer evenings in Los Angeles. They're the best. This was another one of those. And it's one of my fondest memories from shooting the show
在外面拍摄。我之前谈过这个，当我和约翰在屋顶上拍那场戏时，帕姆和吉姆吃烤奶酪三明治。那是洛杉矶温暖的夏夜之一。那是最好的。这是其中之一。这是我拍摄该剧最美好的回忆之一
because I got Steve all to myself and I got Miguel Arteta all to myself. And Mindy was there, and it was just us doing this scene, getting it just perfect. It felt like we had all the time in the world. There was no rush. And, ugh, I just absolutely loved it. Yeah, well, Mindy mentioned, you know,
因为我独自拥有了史蒂夫，我独自拥有了米格尔·阿泰塔。明迪也在那里，我们只是在做这场戏，把它做得非常完美。感觉我们有全世界的时间。没有匆忙。而且，呃，我绝对喜欢它。是的，好吧，明迪提到，你知道，
that she was kind of jealous of her parents that they got to have this great scene with Steve because there are several characters, myself included, that rarely got to have one-on-one scenes with Steve. It just wouldn't make sense in the world of the show. And whenever I did, it felt so special. And I think you got to have some amazing scenes with him throughout the course of the show.
她有点嫉妒她的父母，因为他们能和史蒂夫有这场精彩的戏，因为有几个角色，包括我在内，很少能和史蒂夫有单独的戏份。这在节目的世界里说不通。每当我这样做时，都感觉非常特别。我认为你在整个节目中和他有一些精彩的戏份。
And this is just one of those that was just beautiful and so fun and funny and cringy and heartfelt. Just all of it. That's all true. Angela, we did have someone write in with an old tech alert that I thought you would appreciate. Hit me up. How'd I miss it? What is it? Kayla Whitehead said Pam's cell phone is such old tech, but she's like, but also when she walks outside, Michael sees her on the steps and he notices that she's holding her phone and he says, expecting a call. She was like, no one would say that to you today. If you have your phone in your hand today, no one's like expecting a call because we always all have our phones in our
这只是其中之一，非常美丽、有趣、尴尬且感人。就是这样。那都是真的。安吉拉，我们确实有人写信提到了一个旧技术警报，我想你会喜欢的。告诉我。我怎么错过了？是什么？凯拉·怀特黑德说帕姆的手机是如此古老的技术，但她说，还有，当她走到外面时，迈克尔在台阶上看到了她，他注意到她拿着手机，他说，在等电话吗？她说，今天没人会那样对你说。如果你今天手里拿着手机，没人会说“在等电话”，因为我们总是把手机拿在
hands. That is a brilliant catch. I am applauding that catch. I love that observation. That is an amazing observation because back then, yeah, your phone was in your purse. It was, we didn't walk around holding phones, like flip phones like that, because we did hardly anything with them other than talk to someone.
手里。那是一个精彩的捕捉。我为那个捕捉鼓掌。我喜欢那个观察。那是一个惊人的观察，因为那时，是的，你的手机在钱包里。它在，我们不会拿着手机走来走去，像那样的翻盖手机，因为除了和某人说话，我们几乎不用它们做任何事。
So if you're holding it, you'd probably just spoke to someone or you were about to. Yes. That is a great observation. Pretty great. Well, I want to take us back to Stanford because I think there is a moment in this episode that is the happiest we have seen Andy since he
所以如果你拿着它，你可能刚和某人说过话，或者正要说。是的。那是一个伟大的观察。相当棒。好吧，我想带我们回到斯坦福，因为我认为这一集中有一个时刻是安迪自
has appeared on the show. It's happy Andy and I want to talk, I want to share happy Andy with you. Happy Andy happens at around 15 minutes. They have had a lot of Jaeger. Karen though, she's just tossing her Jaeger shots into the trash. No one knows it. She's not getting wasted. And Andy starts singing acapella. Karen's like, no acapella Andy, but he's drunk
出现在节目中以来我们见过的最快乐的时刻。是快乐的安迪，我想谈谈，我想和你分享快乐的安迪。快乐的安迪出现在15分钟左右。他们喝了很多野格利口酒。不过凯伦，她只是把她的野格利口酒射击扔进了垃圾桶。没人知道。她没有喝醉。安迪开始唱阿卡贝拉。凯伦说，不要阿卡贝拉安迪，但他喝醉了
and he's singing the Indigo Girls, Closer to Fine. And as he drunkenly sings, all of a sudden Jim, who's super wasted, starts joining in and singing. And it's so adorable. Andy's like, tuna, are you kidding me? Like, he's so happy. He's so happy. They're having like an acapella moment.
他在唱Indigo Girls的《Closer to Fine》。当他醉醺醺地唱着时，突然吉姆，他超级醉，开始加入并唱歌。太可爱了。安迪说，金枪鱼，你在开玩笑吗？他太快乐了。他太快乐了。他们像是有了一个阿卡贝拉时刻。
And this is happy Andy. He is thrilled. Well, Angela, we had a fan catch from Renata Torres. She says, at 17 minutes 58 seconds, you can see a pair of white flip flops under Karen's desk. Ah! And she wanted to know if that was on purpose, but we know why those are there.
这就是快乐的安迪。他很兴奋。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了雷娜塔·托雷斯的粉丝捕捉。她说，在17分58秒，你可以看到凯伦桌子下有一双白色人字拖。啊！她想知道那是不是故意的，但我们知道它们为什么在那里。
We do. Those were Rashida's flip flops. Yeah, the wardrobe department would give us Uggs or flip flops to wear to and from our trailers and set so we didn't have to walk in our kind of like high heel office shoes, right? Yeah. Yes.
我们知道。那是拉什达的人字拖。是的，服装部门会给我们UGG或人字拖，让我们穿在房车和片场之间，这样我们就不用穿着那种高跟办公室鞋走来走去，对吧？是的。是的。
You caught Rashida's flip flops. You know, wardrobe actually told me one time also, our trailers were not close to the soundstage. It was a little, you know, quite a walk. And they said that also they would take our shoes to protect our shoes. Because if we walked across the parking lot back and forth, and sometimes if there was weather of any kind,
你抓住了拉什达的人字拖。你知道，服装部门有一次也告诉我，我们的房车离摄影棚不近。那有点，你知道，相当远的路。他们说他们也会拿走我们的鞋子来保护我们的鞋子。因为如果我们来回穿过停车场，有时如果天气不好，
they preferred actually to leave our shoes on set by our desk rather than us walking around in them all the time. And we were delighted because that meant less time in heels. We had our travel shoes. Those were Rashida's travel shoes. Well, as they're leaving for the night in Stanford, Jim is going to ride that bike home. He's going to ride his bike home. Or is he? Well, yeah.
他们实际上更喜欢把我们的鞋子留在片场的桌子旁，而不是让我们一直穿着它们走来走去。我们很高兴，因为这意味着穿高跟鞋的时间更少了。我们有我们的旅行鞋。那是拉什达的旅行鞋。好吧，当他们晚上离开斯坦福时，吉姆要骑那辆自行车回家。他要骑自行车回家。还是他？好吧，是的。
He falls over. Well, you know, it's the end of the night at Stanford. They've had Jaeger, they've bonded over Indigo Girls. I mean, Andy's busting out his air mattress. He's like... Oh, yeah. He's staying in for the night. Jim is gonna try to ride his giant bicycle with the big basket home and he like tips over into the bushes and Karen's in her car. She's like, hold up, get in my car, drunky. And Jenna, do you remember how freaked out people were about this moment? Yeah. I mean, people thought Karen was shady, that she let them get so wasted and that that was she waiting for Jim? Like she had planned it all along.
他摔倒了。好吧，你知道，这是斯坦福夜晚的结束。他们喝了野格利口酒，因为Indigo Girls建立了联系。我是说，安迪正在拿出他的充气床垫。他说……哦，是的。他今晚要留下来。吉姆要试着骑他那辆带大篮子的巨大自行车回家，他像是在灌木丛里翻车了，凯伦在她的车里。她说，等等，上我的车，醉鬼。珍娜，你还记得人们对这一刻有多抓狂吗？是的。我是说，人们认为凯伦很阴险，她让他们喝得那么醉，那是她在等吉姆吗？就像她一直计划的那样？
Yeah, was she waiting out in the parking lot for Jim? And was like, hey, Mr. Tipsy, get in my car. And remember, in this episode, it was written that they were gonna like kiss. Oh, I talked to Rashida about it. I texted with her and I want to read you guys what she said. She said in this episode, they had written a scene where Jim and Karen
是的，她在停车场等吉姆吗？然后说，嘿，醉醺醺先生，上我的车。还记得吗，在这一集中，剧本写的是他们会接吻。哦，我和拉什达谈过这件事。我和她发了短信，我想读给你们听听她说了什么。她说在这一集中，他们写了一场戏，吉姆和凯伦
get sloppy drunk and make out. So maybe I guess she had been drinking too in that different version, right? In that different version because I have the scripted version of that, they the three of them go to a bar and they all get drunk together at a bar and then they were supposed to make out on the street outside of this bar. Yeah and Rashida said they actually filmed the scene in the parking lot. Yeah and she said she was really worried she was like everyone's gonna hate me and then she told me Stephen Merchant actually suggested that they cut the scene out. That he got to watch over because Stephen and Ricky would watch our episodes, and they would give the producers notes.
喝得烂醉如泥并亲热。所以也许我猜她在那个不同版本里也喝了酒，对吧？在那个不同版本里，因为我有那个剧本版本，他们三个人去了一家酒吧，他们都在酒吧里喝醉了，然后他们本应该在酒吧外面的街上亲热。是的，拉什达说他们确实在停车场拍了那场戏。是的，她说她真的很担心，她说每个人都会恨我，然后她告诉我斯蒂芬·莫昌特实际上建议他们删掉那场戏。他负责监督，因为斯蒂芬和瑞奇会看我们的剧集，他们会给制片人反馈。
Rarely, but sometimes. And their notes were always correct. Well. They were always like, they knew, don't move that needle so far. Yeah. And Rashida said she felt like Stephen really understood the relationships, and that this was going too far, too bold,
很少，但有时会。他们的反馈总是正确的。好吧。他们总是，你知道，不要把那根针拨得太远。是的。拉什达说她觉得斯蒂芬真的理解这些关系，而且这太过分了，太大胆了，
too quickly, and bold, too quickly. And it would sort of sabotage anything that Jim and Karen might, could possibly be as a foil for Pam. It was just too much. Yeah, I think if you wanted to believe in their relationship, which you will, like Jim and Karen are gonna really have a great relationship, you don't want it to start off
太快了，大胆，太快了。这会破坏吉姆和凯伦作为帕姆的陪衬可能成为的一切。这太过分了。是的，我认为如果你想相信他们的关系，你会的，就像吉姆和凯伦真的会有一段很棒的关系，你不想让它开始于
with like a sloppy drunk make out in the drunk make out on the side of the street. Kids, are you listening? Nothing good happens after midnight. Okay, go home. This is what my aunt told me when I went off to college. She said, here's my advice to you about sleeping around. This is what she said. She said, you're gonna go to these parties,
像街边的烂醉亲热。孩子们，你们在听吗？午夜之后没好事。好吧，回家吧。这是我上大学时我阿姨告诉我的。她说，这是我关于乱搞给你的建议。她是这么说的。她说，你要去参加这些派对，
you're gonna do some drinking, and you might in the moment want to make a decision that's impulsive. She said, my advice to you is go home because you can always wake up in the morning and say, Oh, I wish I'd slept with that guy. And you can do something about it. But you can't undo. You can't undo. Yeah, I'm with your aunt. You can't undo. But I was kind of lame in college. When I turned 21, I had a big paper due for a class I was taking. And all my friends were like, you're going to go out. It's your 21st birthday. And I said, Oh, no, I need to work on my paper. So I worked on my paper. And my dad had a Texaco gas card. and he would pay my Texaco gas card.
你要喝点酒，你可能会在当下想要做一个冲动的决定。她说，我的建议是回家，因为你总能在早上醒来说，哦，我希望我和那个家伙睡了。你可以做点什么。但你不能撤销。你不能撤销。是的，我同意你阿姨的。你不能撤销。但我大学时有点逊。我21岁时，我有一篇大论文要交，是我正在修的一门课。我所有的朋友都说，你要出去。这是你21岁生日。我说，哦，不，我需要写我的论文。所以我写了我的论文。我爸爸有一张德士古加油卡。他会付我的德士古加油卡。
Just like reality bites, I would go to that gas station and I would get gas, bread, sandwich meat, potato chips, soda, like everything. And I went to Texaco and I bought myself a Coronita. It's not even the big Corona, it's a coronita. It's not even the big corona, it's a coronita. Because I was 21 and I went and I worked on my term paper and I had my coronita and that was my 21st birthday. That is literally adorable. That is adorable. I was a big dork lady. That's why we would have been friends. I would have hung out with you and your cat. We would have been besties. This is also why as adults,
就像《现实的创痛》，我会去那个加油站，我会买汽油、面包、三明治肉、薯片、苏打水，就像所有东西。我去了德士古，给自己买了一瓶小科罗娜。那甚至不是大科罗娜，是小科罗娜。那甚至不是大科罗娜，是小科罗娜。因为我21岁了，我去写了我的学期论文，我喝了我的小科罗娜，那就是我的21岁生日。那真是太可爱了。那太可爱了。我以前是个大书呆子，女士。这就是为什么我们会成为朋友。我会和你还有你的猫一起玩。我们会成为最好的朋友。这也是为什么作为成年人，
we mixed sushi with a lot of hard liquor. And then- Because we didn't learn in college. We didn't learn. Where are we at? I don't even know where we're at, except that Karen put Jim in his car and now we go back to Diwali
我们混合了寿司和大量烈酒。然后——因为我们在大学里没学到。我们没学到。我们在哪？我甚至不知道我们在哪，除了凯伦把吉姆放进他的车里，现在我们回到排灯节。
and it's one of my favorite moments ever. Dwight and Michael are gonna perform a cover of Adam Sandler's Hanukkah song, dedicated to Indians everywhere. Yes, the crowd loves it. Angela, so many people wrote in asking about this song. Was it improvised? A lot of people thought that because Steve was holding a piece of paper that maybe we wrote this on the fly. No, this was in the script. And in fact, Kent told me it had been in the script as far back as the pre-table draft. This is kind of a writer's term,
这是我最喜欢的时刻之一。德怀特和迈克尔要表演亚当·桑德勒的《光明节之歌》，献给全世界的印度人。没错，观众们很喜欢。安吉拉，很多人写信询问这首歌。它是即兴创作的吗？很多人这么认为，因为史蒂夫手里拿着一张纸，可能我们是临时写的。不，这是剧本里写好的。事实上，肯特告诉我，这在剧本预读稿阶段就已经写进去了。这算是编剧的一个术语，
but they send out a draft of the script before they let anyone see it, and they have to give it to all of the main producers so that they can start planning wardrobe and locations. And Kent said that at that pre-table draft, this was the tag for the episode and it remained there until we shot it. So they got permission and all that kind of stuff. And he said, Steve asked for that piece of paper because he felt like his character wrote it at the party. And that would sell the idea that this was like a last minute idea by Michael.
他们在让任何人看到剧本之前会先发出一份草稿，必须交给所有主要制片人，这样他们才能开始规划服装和场地。肯特说，在那个预读稿阶段，这就是这一集的结尾彩蛋，直到拍摄时它一直都在。所以他们获得了许可之类的东西。他说，史蒂夫要那张纸是因为他觉得他的角色是在派对上写的。这能让观众相信这是迈克尔临时起意想到的。
Yeah, yeah. I thought the same thing. I thought Michael, Michael needed those notes. Steve did not. Right. Yeah. Well, it's so good. And I have a really great catch. I'm going to call it a BFF catch. What is it? At 20 minutes, 34 seconds, after he's finished singing and it pans to the crowd and everyone cheers you and I are sitting side by side on the floor together. Oh my gosh, Angela, you know we did that ourselves. I know we sat together.
是的，没错。我也这么想。我以为迈克尔，迈克尔需要那些笔记。史蒂夫不需要。对。是的。嗯，这太棒了。我有一个非常棒的发现。我要称之为“闺蜜发现”。是什么？在20分34秒，他唱完歌，镜头扫向人群，每个人都在欢呼，你和我并排坐在地板上。天哪，安吉拉，你知道那是我们自己坐那儿的。我知道我们坐在一起。
We probably were. I mean, I remember them doing that song. We were all just elated and along for the ride. It was so fun. And I think we, I think we just sat next to each other because they probably weren't even sure if they were going to use that big swing back to the crowd, right? Yeah. And so there we are.
我们可能当时就在那儿。我的意思是，我记得他们唱那首歌的时候。我们都非常高兴，沉浸在其中。太有趣了。我想我们，我想我们只是坐在彼此身边，因为他们可能甚至不确定是否会用到那个扫向人群的大镜头，对吧？是的。所以我们就出现在那里了。
There we are on the ground next to each other. BFF catch. That is the perfect way to end this podcast episode of Diwali. We did it with a BFF catch. We did it. And thank you so much to Mindy Kaling For stopping by I just felt like we could kept talking and talking and I can't wait for her to come back And if you guys get a chance go check out Mindy's new show that she co-created with Lang Fisher. It's so cute It's a coming-of-age kind of comedy drama called Never Have I Ever, and the cast is wonderful and the writing is great.
我们就坐在地上，挨在一起。闺蜜发现。这是结束这期《排灯节》播客节目的完美方式。我们用一个“闺蜜发现”结束了。我们做到了。非常感谢敏迪·卡灵的到来，我觉得我们可以一直聊下去，我迫不及待想让她再来。如果你们有机会，去看看敏迪和兰·费舍尔共同创作的新剧。那是一部非常可爱的成长类喜剧剧情片，叫《好想做一次》，演员阵容很棒，剧本也写得很好。
And you guys, if you watch it, you'll see Angela on it because Angela's in it in a couple of episodes. Yes, I'm in two episodes. I play the mom. I play one of her nemesis's mom and it was really fun. I'll be the mom all day long, Jenna. I know. Yeah, casting folks out there, if you need a mom with a little bit of sass give me a call. You know where to go. Guys thank you so much this was a really fun one and we will be back next week with Branch Wars. See you then. Bye.
伙计们，如果你们看了，会看到安吉拉在里面，因为安吉拉在其中几集里有客串。是的，我演了两集。我演妈妈。我演她其中一个死对头的妈妈，真的很有趣。珍娜，我整天演妈妈都行。我知道。是的，各位选角导演，如果你们需要一个有点个性的妈妈，给我打电话。你知道去哪找我。伙计们，非常感谢，这一集真的很有趣，我们下周会回来聊《分部战争》。到时候见。再见。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil.
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。 《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。